to
hi everybody Ethan Klein here who was
just bit got injured by sitting
thank you everybody it's Friday Baby Woo
May 19th I was just sitting here
just sitting here ah
and I was just telling Ethan how good it
looked everyone was telling me how good
I looked and then I go oh thanks and
then I go
I don't know what happened something on
my neck up
ah it's so I need a neck brace can we
get a neck brace and I can't dude hurt
himself
incredible yeah you're a right athlete I
think I have a neck brace coming today
actually what I can't today by nine
o'clock yeah it was it was for a meme
something unrelated but are you serious
nasty big stinking neck magic you are
you serious you ordered a neck brace
unrelated I swear to God that's so weird
I was I was cosplaying as Mike from
Jersey Shore when he hit his head on a
wall so I was gonna wear a neck brace
with sunglasses and it's coming today so
well it's gonna be too late for me
oh [__] yeah what is it like plastic or
does it have like well I mean from a
drugstore can you send me a photo sure
you got to be careful when you get over
40. I'm not over here a few years past
oh that's personal injuries that's what
I want crop up well it says arriving by
now that was the one that I ordered oh
that's when you ordered yeah so wait
where's the one that you
ah dude
I [__] hate this I'm not even over 40
Dan shut up idiot did you hurt maybe you
hit your head you seemed confused
um
[Music]
you know you know how old I am tell them
yeah
so funny yeah you want that I definitely
want that on it there look at the photo
you guys
[__] this sucks
it's happened to me before it doesn't
happen very often but I'll pull
something like a muscle and it hurts for
like a week old man
that happened to me like the leg muscle
yeah that's the worst one yeah a cramp
and it would just hurt for like a week I
think I'm maybe just having like a
severe neck cramp like it just you know
what I mean so this is what I need I
need a cervical collar gentle support
that's what I need gentle be gentle
it includes a cloth grab it's easy
application and it's net made with
natural rubber latex love that
excellent how much is it
I'm curious the quality of the product
it is hold on it's like five bucks
that's pretty funny do you see what
you're 35
okay that's a decent price oh my yeah
this is avi's face mask that he uses
apparently a b uh he offered this to me
by the way yeah
um I guess your face gets hot when you
eat a glue yes serum Foods I think it's
gluten but I walk around the office
wearing that then I have one at home as
well
I've seen him like this yeah I wonder if
this would be really good for my skin
is it good to reduce like puffiness
Olivia
I think in terms of inflammation ice is
known to decrease what about like pores
like does it make your pores smaller
I don't know about that you have one of
these too right
I do know very quickly that in store if
you were to buy that neck brace at 21.99
so Sam has a lot of similar issues to me
she has like a full Ironman suit of
different uh yeah that's like Iron Man I
have ice socks I have ice mask I have an
ice helmet like mittens I have
everything it's like a super villain art
I hate being hot but I also I have a
gluten allergy and whenever I eat gluten
I get like burning up wow that's crazy
so do you eat gluten knowing that's
gonna happen and then you're prepared
yes okay I I try to avoid it but
sometimes I want to quad
s that's right you've seen this in
action Ian did this shock you the first
time she busted out her ice sculpturing
Mr Dr free [__]
uh no I mean the socks I she bought me a
pair when we were talking long distance
she mailed some to me oh my god oh yeah
she got you ready for that early oh yeah
yeah that was early on but the socks are
nice they are nice so what I don't think
I'm gonna try this on my face I got a
good it is it actually the mask seems
quite nice it fits my face pretty nicely
we have the um the glass things with the
water right yeah I think yeah the beauty
segment if you want I use that on my
neck
um yeah do we have those here yeah let
me go see oh my God that is amazing wait
so what are the feet ones for it don't
is that like people with like diabetes
have puffy they I think the ones that I
have like are intended for people with
diabetes
but the one I for whatever reason at the
end of the day especially in the summer
my feet are so hot and I cannot go to
bed with hot feet
so wait you keep them in the freezer
yeah and they have beads like this
uh the the ones that I have are like gel
packs inside of like socks holy [__]
yeah
there it is hey Gabe
[__]
baby where are you at today
I'm at a shoe store I'm trying to look
I'm trying to buy those um
[__]
Travis Scott Jordan Travis Scott drop
the new shoe really
it looks like it they look at Splash
let's go get one here let's join you can
we see it yeah let's go get the shoe
unfortunately
the store they they it's supposed to be
shoot plugs but they close it and they
turn into a barber shop [__] oh I'm
disappointed so you're not in front of a
shoe store it was the shoe store like
before maybe The Barbers have some maybe
they left some in the back it's a grand
opening yeah
that's what it is
well maybe
yeah since we're here you know
nah don't don't touch your hair your
hair looks great man yeah I love what
you did there
[__] [__]
all right well now so you're gonna go to
a fan of Travis Scott
I just like the style of shoes Travis
Scott is good I just like I just like
the um fashion of the shoes is he the
guy that killed all those people at the
show did you know about that Stampede
what happened in Houston
yeah just be careful if you go to one of
his shows okay
I gotta have a guard with me
that's what's up [__] [__] baby
so you are you off to another shoe store
um I'm trying to find one but
it's kind of like I think you have to go
to the mall or something or especially
yeah I don't think regular shoe store
will have it apparently they're going
for sixteen hundred dollars depends on
the style
are you prepared to try that much Gabe
we'll see here they are if somebody
knows me give me a wow those are fly
am I gonna I'm not like a sneaker guy
but those look kind of like
they look like normal shoes
yep look at uh find the name of the
shoes another pair they make like
reverse mocha there's a bunch of
different color combinations but they
are very expensive yes look at the the
mocha my favorite uh my favorite Travis
Scott shoe there's one actually
commemorating uh the Stampede it's just
got like
it's got like pictures of all these
slain people and stuff it's super hot
blood red it's awesome yeah
I got one of those shoes the only thing
I would change is the inner sole I I
gotta I gotta feel comfortable walking
under shoes those kind of shoes you put
them on they feel like flat they hurt
your feet after a while so I gotta put
better inner Souls [__] that
wait these are just Air Jordans what's
Travis Scott Jordan it was a special
collaboration uh that uh Travis did with
Nike
um okay Fantastical I hope you find it
buddy I'm I'm always rooting for you in
whatever Endeavor you're pursuing shoes
yeah alcohol women whatever it is I got
your back you understand [__] baby [__]
[__] in my dick [__] [__] in my dick
[__] on my title okay suck it suck it
hey
force feed me [__] and suck it out of my
tits like a baby [__]
[__] me [__] yeah
any uh fun plans uh for the weekend
yeah just Woos it's all about sports
baby
cuddling and snuggling and [__] [__]
wait what huggling yeah you said it's
all about sports it's all about
snuggling I didn't understand that yeah
watching sports with some babes and just
stumble babes wait wait wait wait wait
wait are you snuggling with someone this
weekend
um I don't know yet we'll see okay we're
just manifesting
yeah no it's manifesting right now we
don't have any prospects necessarily but
maybe the universe will intervene
is that right
yeah sure okay
Gabe listen you're the greatest man that
ever did it with the Woos and the wheeze
and the was up the Wazoo
we got weak Zoo deep in there deep deep
in the Wazoo my friend is where you'll
find me going
[Music]
laughs
you got me this time you're getting
better at it and it's two weeks in a row
you're getting the last one all right
Gabe you have a great weekend okay we
love you have a good weekend
[Applause]
who the [__] is Uncle Dave
who's the [__] is Uncle game yeah
oh here's oh here's some pictures of you
at um
Zach's show I thought you got on stage
oh yeah that was pretty exciting yeah
Nick Nick a b a b this picture is so
good this is a really pretty I actually
this is a great one yeah
that was an awesome time glad you have
fun buddy we'll see you hopefully we'll
see you on at our live show right in
June sure sure oh of course it's a plan
[__]
all right buddy have a great one okay we
love you have a great weekend
[__] in my [__] [__] under my
fingernails and then and then
and then uh finger paint
yeah I'm I I'm running out of it frankly
too yeah to do there all right Gabe love
you bud see ya all right
[Music]
that's white clock Gabe everybody
the Beloved
[Music]
I'm suffering by the way thank you
Ashley pizza for the massive gifted so
nice of you wasn't there another one too
I think you better get that pizza party
Chrissy Chrissy Sherlock oh yeah Chris
Sherlock huge thank you so much wow
that's a hundred yeah that's crazy
average Eric dude
um stance Charlie uh oh uh average
height Eric okay I'm glad you let that
out in the beginning you know what I
mean I didn't have to ask
uh Ethan your boy Charlie just put out a
tone deaf video on idubbbz and he just
called out well Charlie's not my boy in
any sense I see a lot of people don't
like Ethan and that's totally yeah
I mean I don't have beef with Charlie I
mean it's not my boy I mean [__] but I
do actually want to watch go over
idubbbz uh video and
um
I did see Charlie's video I watched it
right before we went live and I actually
have a comment about that too me too
brother
oh really and Bible but before we do
that let's not ignore that Queen zebra
Queen zebra yes we love her stand up
stunt on them oh for the Zeb okay keep
it going she is cheating on me you can
see her bro it's all falling apart oh
God
and you feel comfortable going outside
in that
um
I was trying to think of a joke
nothing came to mind they would say that
but it's so funny because like I mean
the beach Paradox like the you know
these they're I don't get it what is
wrong with people anyway whatever
yeah so you look awesome I think I've
got some good photos
yes we did
fun you guys also you and Lena and your
crew you have crazy Squad goals you guys
went to a um yeah Teletubby
I was like the [__] okay so I started a
team Ela email and I put it on my
Instagram bio because I'm trying to
Branch out
get some deals maybe so
um Taylor has been going over my email
and every time she's like oh we got this
invite for this one's probably the movie
premiere and I'm like what movie I don't
know the movie me and then she we were
all together we did a shoot this week
tati the one in purple she's a the
photographer that did the really cool
photo shoot I just posted with the
butterflies
um so we were all doing a shoot and
Taylor was just reading me this email
she was like we just got this invite for
a Teletubbies pop-up
they weren't selling anything what the
[__] are they doing there they're just
you know Teletubby has been like kind of
like really cool Taylor was showing me
on Tick Tock yeah if you check their
Tick Tock they're like posting slay
memes and stuff but what what's their
product who are they what are they
selling I don't know I'll probably still
making they're kind of big they're kind
of big with the
um like
transgender and gay community apparently
too okay so there were a few like Queens
out there okay at the pop-up yeah the
show ended in 2001 like what's happening
what why are the Teletubbies doing
pop-ups and so we show up at the pop-up
and it was such a weird mixture of
people like there was only maybe one kid
mostly adults
and when when we showed up the lady was
like oh the Teletubbies are gonna come
out in 10 minutes
Teletubbies came out they came out
mascot's fully clothed yes who's paying
for this they don't selling anything
they don't have a show they're not
selling anything I don't understand is
George Soros funding this to uh erode of
America they had a mural there was music
going on it was really loud and there
was a mural of them on the wall yeah and
this guy was everybody by the way
everybody loved us because we showed up
like the most you have a team yeah and
so they gave us this markers and they're
like do you guys want to sign on the
mural
and I there was music going and he said
apparently anywhere but the face and I
heard the face oh my God and I thought
he said like go for the face or
something like that
you did that I went and I did it on the
face oh no and then he looks at me and
he's like I said anything about the
fight
oh no I couldn't believe it the artist I
don't even know who what I don't know no
not I don't know what it was it was
working that's awesome I mean that's sad
it's horrible but also awesome they're
rebooting Netflix is rebooting them okay
that's what's happening there it is
awesome we had some like hair plans that
was going to be really cool but it
didn't work out but still we arrived and
it's like everyone stopped and just
looked at us they were amazed did they
feed you guys did you get drinks like
what's happening there what do you do
there
I have no idea people just like chatting
with each other right we we came for
Content you know so what's there's no
activities you just sit there you just
stand there and talk about Teletubbies I
don't get this have you ever seen
Teletubbies it's just like they're just
kind of wandering around and open feet
it's very in the vibe they had a few
like uh cases showing some of the
Teletubbies collabs I guess that's
happened over the years so there was
like some display of Teletubbies apparel
Teletubbies boots they had goodie bags
they had goody bags in the goodie bag a
cookie and something
Teletubby figurine a cookie in a juice
box
perfect for nap time
here actually is um
the squad and then tati she's like a
tick tock Mastermind apparently so she
was telling me what to do on Tick Tock
yeah I don't know why I didn't get
invited I know if you know but I
actually
not a little cameo in the Original
Series
yeah I'm sorry
is that a joke are you serious that is
the sun no I'm the son okay I thought I
don't know if you were referring because
I just showed it and I don't know if
you're referring to like maybe you were
a baby in that show sometimes
he was the baby
okay well welcome back Teletubbies and
here we are talking about it so uh
Making Waves entertainment industry they
actually reached out today if we want to
do anything for 31st right now that
could be fun actually that would be a
fun license yeah
it depends how much creative freedom
they'll give us I think they do have you
seen type uh green Teletubbies boots
because sometimes when you work with
these IPS some of them are super cool
and some are like you cannot yeah do
anything you can't even have your brand
near our Brand's text
the characters can't interact they can't
overlap it's like chill the [__] out why
am I doing this then I'm just making
merch oh Teletubbies green boots
green boots I sent
yo what the [__] who made these I don't
remember but it's I think it's like a
high-end brand oh I'm sure yeah dude
that's Christian Cohen you want to know
how much these babies are 2500 let's get
it
still in stock apparently uh
not exactly a line around the block for
these but uh
why
[Music]
maybe they made too many huh I would
have made like five of these
I'm seeing a photo of Anne Hathaway
wearing them let me see that okay
I got this one I would wear those so
hard I love them they're available I'm
actually surprised it's not sold out to
be honest
let's see designer
uh boots and halfway let's see it
okay come on dude I just want to see the
feet that's it what the kind of [__]
photos
not only is it fake she says
it's such a bad Photoshop it's such a
bad Photoshop and even if it was real I
can't even see your [__] feet also
they look horrible with that outfit most
importantly yeah yeah so there you go
nobody is actually wearing this
apparently
but uh thanks for that
yeah so I think it'd be fun I think you
when you work with someone like that you
just gotta we gotta be up front and be
like okay we're down but only if we can
like fool full on yeah full like crazy
control exactly yes oh by the way thank
you to Shopify wow what a great sponsor
huge love Shopify man that's our sponsor
today yeah oh yeah my fave
um today before we get into the main
topics I want to first of all thank our
members thank you guys so much just a
reminder every Tuesday members get a
live show with yours truly you get BTS
crew reactions to lore videos access to
Discord participate in polls and chats
Early Access to Live show tickets which
apparently is more valuable than I
thought
and uh you support the show most
importantly and you get my phone number
my personal phone yep yep tons of
content behind the uh the membership but
thank you to everybody who supports the
show and one other thing teddyfresh.com
the Classics Collection is here I was uh
explaining a few times on the show the
kind of
the goal that the thesis of this
collection which was to
in response to inflation into these
incredibly raising prices of everything
and our braising price of doing Goods
shipping uh materials everything was
skyrocketing yeah and so we sat down
when this started happening and we're
looking over our margins and looking
like damn we're having to raise our
prices like this this is crazy and then
well we said well what if we actually
go the other way what if in response we
love we do something that's even cheaper
than anything we've made before
also we always see the comments there's
always so many people say you know I
wish I could afford it's just out of my
price range so it's also taking all
those people in mind that can finally
get an opportunity to you know take a
little piece join the party
um and also previously when we did the
classics
I made a stupid mistake of like
adding a really cool wash that made it
really beautiful but then it was
expensive it wasn't even like a cheaper
price range no which you know kind of
like is what you would expect from a
Basics or core not Basics
um Classics Collection baby just saying
that's what you would normally expect so
um this time when we talked about this I
had to really restrain myself
and it was like we are not adding
anything no wash no embroideries no
bells and whistles perfect Silhouettes
really nice clean yeah just the rare
patch it it was so hard by the way to do
that
um but then I was so happy that it
actually came to fruition and our team
did so well I was selling them yesterday
that I'm just so happy with everybody
I'm wearing that helps make it happen I
love these shirts I think this is all
I'm going to be wearing from now on I
think everybody's rocking it at least
this week I don't know maybe you wearing
one
oh this is the first day I'm not no it's
all good that's hot um but um I did want
to give an update I don't know if you
have it in the dock oh I just want to
say that you guys are gonna love the
quality this stuff
is high-end beautiful fabric you're
gonna love it and at the price it's it's
honestly it's stunning 20 hat twenty
dollar shirt you have to love it this
the pocket tee is 22. I mean I'm just
saying and uh we're gonna hopefully
bring some more colors uh as time goes
on and stuff and rotate keep it fresh
but you guys absolutely love this stuff
uh you wanna what what update did you
want me to read basically that next
Thursday
um the women's stuff is arriving so
and a few of the men's styles that are
sold out it's because we didn't get the
full quantity okay so next Thursday some
stuff will be added
if there was something you wanted you
can sign up to the back in stock mailer
too and you'll get a notification this
is the bear ears hoodie the classic
sweatpants the women's this is all
coming next week so the women's and some
of the men's stuff sold out that's right
and everything in between
so that's it thank you guys for your
support on that and I I promise you guys
are gonna absolutely love the quality of
this I I that's I guarantee it
you wouldn't just take out a loan this
isn't my first rodeo it's just alone
it's just a it's just a t-shirt this
isn't my first rodeo you guys I
guarantee it okay so there you go fun
fun good things there
um okay
so do you guys know Alex Pardee he's
like a
accomplished artist a friend of the show
actually a fan of the show such a good
guy such a sweet guy cam you're actually
really good friends with them right
all right
I think all of us here yeah yeah I'm a
long-term fan I've been a fan of this
since I don't know 2010 something like
that and uh and really wild that he
watches the show yeah we were all
individually following him right yeah
dude related to each other because we
knew of him I I found his work in 2007
uh he did a lot of art for the band they
used back in the day and I fell in love
with his work and he's been an enormous
inspiration on my work for
since before high school yeah sorry you
caught me off guard I'm hoping we're
gonna edit right now it's all good but
he's a uh he's amazing he's and also he
he's such a fan he was able to buy
tickets to the live stream
what a guy he is so I reached out to him
to do our merch for the live show and to
my surprise or to my uh enjoyment he was
totally down so we're collaborating with
Alex for our live show merch and check
it out this is the poster and the
t-shirts we're gonna be selling but I
want to show you guys because it's so
freaking hype it's so good he's sick and
he's got so many memes in here like
everybody's getting a nod you got the
white claws you've got the butterfly the
chestnuts uh the beach ball some of this
I have to decode I think this is White
Club Gabe Chicken Fried Chicken yeah
there's like one for every crew member
even the boba made it yeah what is the
red p
PowerPoint oh my mind yeah that's you I
love that but I mean the foot one love
got his own little portion down here
hell yeah bunny I just noticed the
prolapse Donuts
yes what a [__] oh he's got the
button it's the button yeah the Mayo can
Mayo 13th
the uh the button
but I don't know why I have got acne I'm
gonna have to talk about that that's
part of his thing it's like he always
loves adding story and
um background to whatever happened to
the character that he's drawing and so
I'm sure something like it's you
something happened to you and are your
dreams he's always breaking out in rash
yeah that's actually true the rash and
the green could be the pesto maybe okay
I'm feeling that that's good backstory a
few of us went to uh his birthday party
it was really cool and we watched he
like rented out of theater we went to
and then yeah that's it he provided like
uh
like some pudding and didn't tell us
what it was for and then later on in the
movie it all correlated at the end it
was pretty cool to add on to what he was
saying yeah you guys like this one piece
uh art well guess what I own this one
it's in my house do you have the
original yeah I own the original here we
are
it's my favorite piece of art it's so
sick it's awesome
[__] stuck but yeah that's Alex and
uh I'm just thankful to him and excited
for everybody too
get their hands on that
um yeah so I want to watch the idubbbz
stuff oh God we have to do this Dan I
don't even know how to Broach we're
actually at uh 30 if you want to uh do
our ad real we have hunger we have a
hunger FF
update
and I don't even know how to touch this
one I need help walking through this
that being said let's thank our sponsor
and then we'll do that
uh hunger's innocent
not to keep you guys on the edge of your
seat Justice for Hunger Justice for
Hunger
but anyway thank you to Shopify
love Shopify I was just talking about
Petty fresh obsessed guess where we've
been since day one and I say this
with full sincerity yeah not one day
have we not not just not regretted but
been so happy that we're on Shopify yeah
I couldn't be happier and I seriously
mean it I couldn't be happier I have
never had the reason to look anywhere
else
and we've never had any issue
Shopify is an e-commerce platform that's
revolutionizing uh millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're
selling uh
this or whether you're selling that you
can do it all
on Shopify
um they have the tools thank you Zach is
that you Dan no no is that oh this this
is uh that's this that's part of the
artery it is yeah that's the sound of
you guys getting paid on Shopify yes sir
um it has all the tools that you need
it's ease of use combined with like the
high level tools customizability is what
makes it so amazing you can step in
there as a novice with no experience
with us in the beginning me and Ila
don't know anything about
making websites
yet yeah we started this Shopify account
just the two of us and figured out how
to set up a store and from there we went
from just the two of us into now Teddy
fresh as you know today with over 30
employees and all this complex plug-ins
from their store that has all these
amazing uh Partners they work with
there's so many apps that we install as
time goes on and we realize oh we need
something for this or for that for
example they have apps for return always
a solution
um the return process you install an app
just for that or fraud alert like there
there can be fraudulent you know um
purchases so you have apps that
completely handle that part dude we got
bones so hard from fraud until we
realized and then we just installed an
app from the app store and then boom it
solved the problem immediately
um even for taxes when you reach a
certain point right for example
at this point for us we needed this tax
app that make sure you collect taxes in
all the states that you need
yeah so it's basically a it has
everything you need every step of the
way and their fan their customer support
is fantastic their platform's fantastic
I just I can't say enough and positive
things about them we've never had our
website has never gone down never and
you know with us being from YouTube
a lot of people would want to mess with
stuff like that and we've never had any
it's never gone down ever so they really
have an amazing service they also have
uh every sales Channel covered from an
in-person POS system to an all one
e-commerce platform it even lets you
sell across social media marketplaces
like Tick Tock Facebook and Instagram
packed with industry-leading tools ready
to ignite your growth shop up for thank
you Zach Shopify gives you complete
control over your business and your
brand without have you having to learn
any new skills in design or code and
thanks to 24 7 help and an extensive
Business course Library Shopify is there
to support your success every step of
the way
now it's your turn to get serious about
selling on Shopify this is uh this
possibility
this is possibility powered by Shopify
sign up for a one dollar per month trial
that's sweet shopify.com after dark all
lower cases that's a one dollar per
month trial let's go go to shopify.com
after dark
to take your business to the next level
that's shopify.com after dark thank you
to them we love them we love them
foreign
so I okay so let me set this up because
I
we
uh you wanna you wanna I don't know I I
yeah
um I don't want to I don't want to like
no it it it's my [__] up
um it's simple there was a
miscommunication there was a
miscommunication
um I was looking back through my
messages with Hunger I never explicitly
told him no
um he asked me about uh what he can have
on his shirt and I think I was more
focused on that and I assume that you
would understand that he didn't
um it is my bad I apologize he's not
malicious in any way shape or form
um he's a great dude
um so I apologize to him I apologize for
any communication uh miscommunication
um and it's my bad I [__] that one up
if you guys are confused are was it
Wednesday's episode
yeah we had to erase and re-upload
because during our
um hunger interview there was fat
prolapsed dildos in the back although I
will say the one that I was more worried
about was the giant to [__] in the
background yeah that wasn't your fault I
had no idea that was gonna yeah that
wasn't your fault
um but yes you cannot Shia so I I
apologize profusely and um he's a good
dude hunger's a good guy he is a good
guy so yeah we apologize to hunger
because I mean we it's not like we went
super hard on him but we there was some
implications possibly thrown around that
he was negligent or potentially even did
it on purpose which uh with the
information we had at the time wasn't
was it was a fair conclusion but knowing
that uh it wasn't communicated on our
end I want to issue an uh um I want to
say Olive Branch but I know there's
a sexual uh imagery I can do instead
like a row like a rose
I want a prolapse donut I don't know um
yeah so anyway uh no hate to uh hunger
oh he's a great dude sweetheart thank
you that's it okay that one's not bad oh
Alex donated Alex party just you didn't
say anything thank you for the donut bro
brodo
okay that was easy that wasn't too bad
actually
I so that Zach uh doesn't have to bear
all of the responsibility I should say
too that I felt bad afterwards I should
have um I should have him called in and
just checked that his frame was ahead of
the show uh I was thinking about it in
retrospect yesterday
um with the fact that we had that
incident with him the first time uh
you know I should have had the thought
like let's just make sure that it's all
good so that that is awesome I mean
should we really be surprised that
hunger had a fat [__] male genitalia
on it and a picture in his background
you know I mean that's what the call was
about right he lives and breatheses no
not the dildos there was a separate okay
the poster yeah right which that you
know I I did think of it that morning
and you know asked hey he knows the deal
right that we can't show lewd stuff and
um like Zach said the focus was on the
shirt because that was the issue last
time
um but uh yeah yeah the dildo was uh the
bigger there it is there it is so anyway
all good we can um I also want to um
shamelessly plug my Vlog morgue pie
donated friend of the show said Eli your
insta's been amazingly at the end I love
the Vlog so much oh thank you oh do you
want to be in my vlog
we should we should um probably do a
little vloggy vloggy vlog oh you want
here let me open it yeah so you you and
Lena have been so long Lena and I are
having so much fun doing the Vlog please
go watch it
thank you
yeah this this one was really nice I
liked it you guys went to this like
high-end uh such an interesting store
designer store like a consignment store
and the lady that was just such a
character he was amazing
yeah it was actually really interesting
I liked it so okay let's move it on here
guys um
we've got some fun stuff at the top
let's do all this uh
okay the pizza dough trick
um this one's been kind of put to rest
right Sam do we
yeah we I didn't see the video of you
with the Frisbee in your backyard yet
though well I haven't been outside yet
in two days okay no not yet
look at this guy what the [__] this
guy's just like dear Sam oh my God
wow
a lot of people think it was fake uh
well we did that already didn't we throw
dough they make special dough yeah so
what it could have been real but now
there's this extra layer of was it
really does wait this is fake though
it's fake dough kidding me why well it's
cool actually scroll down there I
believe there's a video
wait or maybe it's on an original dough
throw I gotta read about this
really a product yeah so it's like
rubbers why are they doing this why are
they doing this so that you can practice
your twirling your people oh that's what
it's not the fake video videos that you
can do it
may have some nefarious purposes you
could use it for as well
could you really get the real experience
from a fake dough I mean how can that be
the dynamic energy of a real dough throw
I agree I agree you say that makes no
sense however this is actually very
nutritious it's true Papa knows
uh here I believe this is a
oh yeah it's on it is on their website
it was on another page
well we should certainly buy one
I think we we got it I'm down yeah I
want to get one of those bad boys on my
hands I'm already on it
okay
let's go girl that's the one from the
product yeah that looks super real it
looks way better in the video than the
pictures I found one that comes with a
DVD with courses on how to do it uh not
the DVD with the DVD I should just
become a pro Doughboy for no reason bro
Doughboy
well uh by the way and one last nod to
the 5-4 man [__] who we were having a
little bit of fun with this is the one
that I like what more we it was just a
bit from uh yeah you didn't really you
didn't really hate on this one oh I
liked him but he was stoked that we
talked about him he's a five or five
more man or yeah and he slid his wrists
I missed that
well let's just get on to it because I
don't waste too much time so let's just
talk about the idubbz thing and then
let's just get into Olivia PowerPoint
and if we have more time we can do all
this kind of fun stuff afterwards but
you know what I mean slam it out oh
pnp's calling is he oh oh yeah let's go
uh literally right now two o'clock
oh Ian's uh
we'll give we'll give you an update in a
second okay okay okay cool so let's just
start the um
yeah so idubbbz made a video uh called I
miss
uh the old idubbbz um
in which he addresses head-on
uh the criticisms he's got for his old
content
um I'm gonna like it
because that's what homies do and
because I liked it
um
you know he's he's been on the receiving
end of a lot of criticism in the same
way that I was
um although I will say back in the day I
think Ian had the
distinct title of King of the edgy kids
yes he was Lord edgy ejimus yeah I think
it's a little bit more extreme case I
was in his orbit I mean we were people
put our names in the same sentence all
the time but um
Ian was King edu and like you know he
had done
pretty questionable things you know what
the one thing that I never really
understood even when it did but
was the um if it's all okay or it's
either all okay or none of it's okay
what she addresses in this video
in terms of like justifying saying the
n-word
which was pretty interesting take and
it's it is you know and let's be real he
the result of that video
specifically the one about Tana he's
unlisted all the content cops
I think he was a little hard on himself
in that but I totally respect just
wanting to own it all and move on yes
like he's just full out you know Palms
open
just let I'm not hedging my bed so I'm
not making any excuses it's just all
down I yeah I I watched it yesterday too
and I personally feel like this is what
I've wanted to see from him for so long
because I feel like any I feel like he
kind of even says it here how
even when he started to kind of like
acknowledge the things he's done it was
still sort of like vague or sort of
defensive-ish about it or things like
that just not always being fully
open and in fact for the first time he's
actually talking openly and I really
like that I have always wanted to see
more of that from him
because it's just that's what people
really want we just want to really hear
you talk and just know you
and I I've been personal friends with
him for a long time you know and so
the dude I know has always been a really
great nice supportive kind person you
know and
um he went through something that I went
through
uh
a few years ago you know I mean you
always knew this was gonna happen to
idubbz2 because we knew the conflict we
knew that
all the kids running around saying the
n-word because idubbb says it was okay
that he was not that's not what he
wanted he was not down in the world yeah
he was not down with that so I guess we
knew the Reckoning was coming because
there's there's just a ton of
reactionary little [__] online
you know and they used to be my fans too
which is what happened to me they just
they don't want to be told that
they don't want to be they don't want to
face it man you know what I mean it's
like
if he's wrong not us
it's hit it's Ian it's Ethan that are
wrong they went soft not us we're right
and they're wrong
and it's not even necessarily like a
condemnation of his fans you know I
enjoy this content back then I mean
everybody enjoyed his content cops I
don't think they were all super
problematic by any means
but somewhere and
it's okay if you enjoyed it like at the
time but like let's just be real about
what it was which is what he's doing
full open Palms
and
you know it's this is this is what
growth is this is what maturing is yeah
this is what it looks like and sadly
it's almost become a virtue today at
least in American culture to not change
that's the virtue like we were watching
what we were watching oh yeah that that
weird Alpha dude arguing with a with a
woman
on one of these red pilled shows yeah
and he goes I will never change yeah you
can tell me 85 different ways and I will
be the same person and it's like well
yeah I loved her response how she was
like isn't that a little bit of a
limited mindset because and yeah because
he was saying the same [__] she was just
quoting him back
and so like it's becoming this virtue to
to grow or somehow growing or changing
your mind it means that you are a liar
means that you're a hypocrite you know
and again I think
I don't know who said this maybe Mark
Twain but it's very good it's very
poignant that um
a hypocrite is sometimes just a man
who's uh
changing
you know what I mean if you Mark Twain
cringe as [__] bro Mark Twain personal
growth cringe you're a [__] was that a
Mark Twain quote we're looking at right
yeah
[__] hypocrite Mark Twain's one of
the coolest ass [__]
people that ever lived
ah but yeah it's uh oh that
what sometimes a hypocrite is nothing
more than a man that is in the process
of changing yeah
um that's a Brandon Sanderson quote
who's that he's like a fantasy author
no definitely not Mark Twain uh he's
he's great though so uh
um great quote I said I think I mean
Lego boy he's not quite my queen Lego
boy
yeah so I really like that quote
because again he goes yeah so saying
apparently telling every all these kids
who looked up to me
that I had a great influence over that
saying the n-word is cool isn't good
and it's incredible to me the amount of
people who
are actually
um
not receptive to this including by the
way
massive YouTubers
uh like Charlie critical
I see a lot of people don't like Ethan
and that's totally fine who's my boy as
someone noted of course Boogie had the
most enlightened enlightened take ever
uh he said y'all think the beating Jordy
gave me was bad check out the beating
items he's giving his career
um
oh boy well let me put it this way okay
people said the same thing about me and
I feel that our career has never been
higher or better people think that
because they don't watch you your career
is over well guess what buggy I mean you
know I don't [__] want you I don't
want people that like saying the n-word
um watching and Ian makes the same point
in his video I don't want
that traffic I don't want those the
audience
and I think what he's doing is is Noble
and again I I relate to it specifically
because I've been through the same thing
but he he what he's done is removed all
doubt exactly and you have to you just
have you can't be vague about this stuff
you know right you're going to continue
to like fence it if you're being vague
about it and you're gonna end up getting
[__] from both sides so just be open and
clear about what you're trying to say
right just don't leave any room for like
interpretation it's the centralist [__]
you gotta just say what you mean man and
he did that and so like all the uh
all the um
the people that used to look up to him
you know they can move on with their
lives and the people that support him uh
can know that he's you know changed and
this is his opinion
but buggy uh talking about anybody's
careers is remarkable I mean
yeah he needs to space out his else a
little bit right
true I mean buggy my God man
it's just such a prime example though a
lot of these dudes they just want to
jump on the hate train they don't even
know what the [__] they're talking about
he thought he's gonna be praised for
this and he just looks like a dumbass
I'm sorry well well that's not exactly
true he got 4 000 likes I don't think
Boogie usually gets that many likes
because it's the easy take and Charlie
did the same thing it's it's the
enlightened centrism there's so many
people that are mad at idubbbz for
apologizing for saying that and telling
people it's okay to say the n word
that's crazy to me and and people don't
they don't want to hear that
uh Boogie paid thousands of dollars to
get his ass beat apparently he lost
money yep so like I mean talk about
taking a beating brother
I mean what was that for dumb dumb uh
yikes you know but this is the easy uh
brownie points you know to get like oh
this guy's lame I've seen all the
commentary channels they're all doing
their tour of like items is sell out
it's lame and Charlie did the light
version of that
where he's like um
I don't think it was that bad I think
it's totally fine to say the n-word I
eat that's not what he said that's not
what he said but like in a sense it is
what he was saying because he's like
that's the problem though when you're
not clear though about that when you're
like
well those videos weren't that bad okay
so let me interpret what do you mean by
that you mean that what he did wasn't
wrong right you mean that I can say it
yeah you know it's like we there you
can't leave that room when on topics
like this that's such that's that's
right
Charlie goes it's not that bad you
didn't need to apologize
and it seems like he even meant like by
today's standard it's fine uh I think
Charlie was just still trying to say Ian
was just being too hard on himself
well I think at certain points he was
being too hard himself but I do think I
think Charlie was trying to toss a bone
to the haters I really do that's the way
I saw it
because he's got a hedge his bets I just
I just think he I just think he
he just tossed in a bone I don't know
what to tell you guys that's my opinion
you know
there was a larger audience that idubbz
was apologizing to
you know it wasn't like yeah maybe he
was too hard on himself at some point
you could say that but the apology
wasn't just meant for you there was a
lot bigger of a community that he was
apologizing to well I think I think it's
funny too that Charlie goes
um you didn't need to apologize as if
he's the representative of like all
black people
who you know felt the consequence of a
bunch of kids spokesmen yeah it's like
cool you're not you're not you're not
the recipient of this like right exactly
like just you know
yeah
so but and of course this is all stuff
I've done right I don't want to make any
uh uh mistakes about it I've done all
this dumb [__] all this racist sexist
[__] [__] we've also had the
Reckoning that's that that Ian is going
through right now I've had the Reckoning
it's painful and frankly there's nothing
really to gain from it other than
personal growth the Reckoning we went
through was one of the worst
times of my life psychologically yeah it
was horrible
was so painful and it was
um like I was in like just a mental
lowest level just so a Battleground in
my mind yeah the just low low low times
but when you come through on the other
end
you know who you are and your fans know
who you are and now I've never been more
honest
I've never been more authentic and the
fans that watch they like me for who I
am right who I really am and I can say
what the [__] I mean
always and I don't have to do what like
Charlie and Boogie's doing where I don't
I don't have to like say cater to some
people so you gotta worry about how you
phrase yourself 100 exactly
and so like the first time that I we got
like massively [__] is when I dared to
criticize PewDiePie for the n-word thing
that was like such a shitstorm Vivo
we're mad about that it's the nuclear
words such a shitstorm and um that was
kind of like the whole spiral down into
that but you know again and I think it
is important to note that part of that
shitstorm was because that you
criticized him before that Reckoning had
really taken place and it kind of I mean
correct me if I'm wrong but that sort of
was the beginning of you sort of trying
to re-analyze like who who is in my
audience who am I catering to who am I
making content for and because you know
it your your past racist remarks and
stuff like that that was the criticism
is like oh you do this you know it's
it's yeah exactly right and that's fair
right right that was fair at the time
yeah because you start to think like oh
but
the the context was there exactly right
because you know you go well I'm not
racist but then you think and you're
like well you can do racist things you
can say racist things
and it doesn't necessarily make you a
hateful racist person
or but but let's just be honest you know
it's harder and racism it's hard to be
honest with yourself it was something
like that you know it's painful but but
the uh yeah the truth is that
when I criticized PewDiePie and I did
think it was wrong what he did and I was
being authentic to myself everybody was
like well you said it so who the [__]
are you nobody was mad that I said the
n-word they were mad that I criticized
PewDiePie right
and that yeah at first my my reaction
was to be defensive right but then over
time
you know you let the the walls down and
you let the truth in
and so
so yeah he's dealing with the Reckoning
and the same Fallen he has the Fallen
fans that I have now you know what I
mean
and I just feel bad because for them too
I mean you know it's
growth is good maturation is good yeah
nobody's gonna who can really tell me
like oh you're maturing means saying the
n-word more
like like who's gonna make that argument
so
uh
oh yeah an important Nissa that is so
[__] up what yeah
she has been before Ian just came out
and did this whole thing
everybody was like blaming Anissa like
Yoko Ono or something or like Anita
Rooney and which is really again just
it's part of the same culture the woman
that he chooses to marry and live his
life with happily
I need to ruined Ian by the way you guys
need to listen to yourself [__]
single in cells who will never touch a
woman
are like dude I'd never date a girl like
that you'll never date anybody
I feel like also personally like this
year
is kind of like my own uh journey of me
discovering myself in a new way like
doing things I never thought I would do
wearing things I never thought I would
wear just seeing myself like confident
things I never I never saw myself as
this person and now I'm doing it and I
feel like I can see the same thing with
Ian when he was talking about how he I
think he never thought he would make a
video like this
right no I don't think so either yeah
and so I'm happy for him that he's doing
something that you never thought he
would do you know because he's never
been open like that and he's talking
about just his feelings just straight up
no one for interpretation
and I'm excited for him I think this is
this is going to be a good he's free
free and it's gonna be a really good
journey for him and now people that will
follow him it's gonna be like quality
people they are there for him for who he
is that's it and they're ready to see
what he's gonna do next being authentic
like truly authentic and honest is the
most powerful thing yes in my opinion
for me as an Entertainer as a as someone
who's online who's you know I'm Brew I
everything in my life is open as
possible
it's the ultimate when you can be fully
authentic you know and you know I don't
ever have to worry about like oh well
did I say that right did I
you know is that gonna piss off the old
fans it's just you don't have to [__]
you don't even have to think you're free
of that now
you remember the days when we would make
a video and we'd be like
oh they're gonna say it's not like the
old videos oh yeah it's like we would
have all these thoughts like can we do a
hundred shirts challenge oh yeah they're
gonna be pissed they're gonna call us
sellouts yeah because we some fans only
wanted this kind of video and other fans
would think 100 shirt challenge was like
I got a lot of [__] for that video yeah
explicitly [__] on somebody is that
why yes no I think because it was just
goofing around right they're like yo
this is like what would they say this is
something you would make fun of yeah
something stupid like they already said
that years ago yeah even though that
videos are great I love that video which
videos are laughing really hard the 100
I mean it's really dumb yeah I was super
dumb but it was fun I love that you know
what I mean and so it's hard not the
first time you were on a Mobility
Scooter oh yes I think it is beginning
of a [__] whole Saga right there
right come on
so like
he did the he took the hard route
this is the hard route make no mistake
everyone like Boogie who's a giant
[__] loser in his own right talk
about a dude who's not authentic at all
I don't think he knows what that word
even means I mean he's the he's
practically the king of the fans
it rules he's been sitting
I'm not King of the fan I'm not gonna
make any joke about that I promise
about him sitting on the fence I wasn't
even thinking about that it's not gonna
happen good good for you
you know nothing about all the king's
horses and All the King's Men
putting him back together again
so what happens when you sit on the
fence yeah sometimes you crack an egg
to make an omelette
so that was Mark Twain Lincoln
[Laughter]
so um I'm proud of him you know
I'm proud of him
he took the Hard Road
but he's free
he's free
and that's what it is man
and it's gonna is don't get you don't
get me wrong it's gonna be [__] hard
to find his bearings again
it took me out it's a journey time it's
a journey yeah
but at the end of the day but this is
for life this is
this is you're you controlling what your
life could be
and setting like starting on a good
foundation it's hard to feel good about
it when you're getting so much like
nastiness
but
ultimately you will
feel good about it I I can't emphasize
enough just how glad I am to have
changed that way and publicly too and I
feel this and I feel this you know what
I mean I feel this it has been it's been
a long painful hard journey for myself
it's been a
and tremendous growth for myself I've
matured so much
it's it's it's actually incredible and
now as a as a father of two kids I can
say that I'm proud of the content we
make
and that I'm not wouldn't be embarrassed
for them to watch it right
uh
you know and and I'm happy with with
what we're doing and so
good for him man that's all I got to say
and anyone else
who's criticizing him is just a sad
loser yeah like genuinely yeah I don't
even know what to say if if you think
that this is some ultimate betrayal
you're just a sad loser
if you want to keep saying the n-word
and being edgy to that I mean just be
like if you leafy just watch leafy right
I mean that's what it is where where
right I say that as a uh to make a point
but literally literally where literally
you know I just hope it doesn't
discourage him at all because I know the
hate must be tough I've never been
anything you know even remotely close to
that but you have but you know both of
you guys there's a reason why you guys
are so popular you guys have a talent
that I think people admire so the change
making that change announcing it and all
that and talking about it is tough but I
hope he continues to push forward and
make content
I'm happy to see that he is getting a
lot of support despite the uh annoying
losers that are criticizing him there is
a good amount of supportive comments on
his videos and uh likes so it's not all
hate but there's there's a lot yeah
um
you know
there it is I'm proud of him well I
don't know what else to say
you just criticized him though what does
that mean Michael
what does that even mean bro
what I don't know
um
trying to think what else there is
really to say about it
uh should maybe mention the uh Tana Ian
thing oh where's that the Tana tweeted
about it so that and again you know when
we go back and I think the one video
that
is probably the most you know effed up
one he made was the Tana one and not
just because the n-word thing but just
the way he kind of like
well I'll read his I'll just read their
interaction
um canceled podcast as soon as possible
Tana said crazy times wonder if he'd
ever come on I have a lot to say
definitely never thought this would
happen
and then Ian responded that he will come
on and she said message you so this is
nice this is the world healing yeah
he's in the snow it is really nice
and tan is another someone you know
that's apparently you know oh yeah a
friend of the show big time
um but she's also someone who's matured
a lot over the years oh yeah you know
so I I'm very opposed to this obscenely
toxic notion that changes weakness
growth is weakness yeah so you people
think if I I will never change because
I'm so authentic it's like no you're
just a coward you're not authentic if
you're worried about what your friends
might say
never
and that's why I think that
some people are giant phonies when they
talk about these topics and it's easy
for like new people to come in and
criticize you guys but like people need
to remember like you him Tanner you guys
were like the first wave I feel like of
like these big creators and uh yeah I
know it was it was a tough learning
experience that you guys kind of had to
do in front of the whole world so
right and we're look a little bit older
I mean Ian's 33 we were in our like mid
to late 20s and the YouTube was the wild
west and we were all funny guys being
crazy and edgy and stuff and you know
it only makes sense that we're all now
at a certain point where we're like yee
you know
time to grow up a little bit and just
and for people to be Ian's total really
poignant story in his video about a
trans fan came up to him and said hey I
know you probably don't like trans
people but can I have a picture with you
and that hit him right because he's like
I I understand why they drew that
conclusion even though
that's crazy right I don't hate trans
people and
that's you know [__] you know that's
just it's sad it's [__] up yeah that's
really sad and you here here by the way
is Mark Twain's famous quote sometimes
you've got a crack an egg to make an
omelette
which is one of his great lines shout
out to whoopies he's an incredible
author I love him man way ahead of his
time my favorite Mark Twain quote is two
fives make a ten
[Music]
what did he say two fives make a ten two
fives make a ten yeah 10.
mine is what time is it that's my
favorite oh that is that is pretty
insightful you're right
good morning I loved when he said that
when he asked uh could you pass the
parmesan cheese for my spaghetti
he did not these are not powerful he
snapped these are not sayings you guys
are just like what put you guys are just
saying really common things all of this
stuff up when he said it yeah yeah no
nobody said it like him what's the
significance of pass me the parmesan
cheese how's that well it was Mark Twain
who said it yeah Mark Twain said that
I'm sure he probably did say that at
some point in his life so it's it's the
Mark Twain quote Yeah of Parmesan
I like when you said If It Ain't About
ass then I ain't with it Mark Twain I
don't know what year that's from though
all right
yeah
um
[Applause]
I'm trying to squeeze my brain not to
leave anything out because
I don't think anybody not many people
can identify with what he's going
through I don't know that there's anyone
else that really knows other than me I
mean can you think of anyone else that's
been through this
like I I don't know
he's coming out as a full-on lib dude
guys like a lib ass like supports trans
and doesn't say the n-word like what a
loser what a loser change dumbass
comedians that have come to kind of
reflect in
change their attitudes as they get older
I guess
um Howard Stern Maybe Howard Stern has
changed a lot yeah that's true and he I
saw saw a tweet the other day that was
like Howard Stern in hot water for
Unearthed comments about women I was
like
what could he have possibly said about a
woman that would be shocking though
something else that was in the video
um was how a clip of him on a podcast
was being used everywhere like the
Anthony Padilla one yeah
yeah what was that I remember seeing
that on my shorts feed people are saying
the Chad that joji and Jenna Marbles are
probably two people
I gotta say about joji like
he was pretty
smart if you go back and look at his
content
may I maybe I'm not speaking correctly
because I I I'm not like a joji like
historian like some people are
but he was pretty smart I feel like and
like obviously his [__] was obscene and
[__] up and gross in a lot of ways but
he's never addressed it though he I
think he doesn't even want to he doesn't
want people to know that Joe G exists or
that or I mean that yeah I mean he
handles it in a different way but yeah I
mean you can read between the lines that
he's very much kind of disavowed that
part of his career yeah oh for sure for
sure he got mad at me even once when I
said
I haven't spoken too many years so I
don't mind saying this
um
I said something about like yo uh
whatever I won't say it then [__] it who
cares but yeah he doesn't like the
association
and then uh Jenna Marbles I feel bad for
what happened to Jenna man
you know it sucks that she got run off
because I mean she's entitled to change
just like all of us and I mean she has
changed she had been changed yeah
it's all Shane Dawson's fault look at
all the things back in the day that all
those people did that [__] up [__]
like blackface and all that it was all
it was always and because of Shane
Dawson it's all his fault even blippi
made a diarrhea on his homie well I
don't think yeah what's the difference
with Shane because like people still
hate Shane well he doesn't really make
content like that anymore well some of
the Shane's crimes were yeah I guess the
the the stuff with kids yeah the stuff
is different I think Janice is more like
not Jenna's like didn't pass the
the time you know it just looks outdated
now and like she shouldn't have made
some of the things but he is more so
like Timeless creepy
your fault yeah Shane is he took it
further I mean some of the [__] Shane
did was like yo that that that's deeper
than
once you have a puppet little girl talk
about how she wants stuff like
like an eight-year-old puppet who wants
to like [__] you and all that [__] he
did with that puppet man that ain't
right
that [__] just ain't right
so
there it is you know good for him
and I I think that anyone who's not
fully supportive of him is is out of
their mind it's just a full self-report
not like the interactions that I had
with fans there were quite a few human
beings that I interacted with that just
sucked because I attracted a lot of
people who suck some people were very
much like anti-social weird basement
dwellers you know the one time a month
that they come out of their cave and
they run into me their favorite YouTuber
what would they saying what would they
do things that I am certainly not going
to repeat because I'm talking bad words
that we only say by describing the first
letter yeah
I did not like yes so I don't I guess
he's
in this short context it seems in a
sense when you're crawling around naked
inside of a storm drain eating pickles
you're bound to attract some degenerates
that's fair
idubbbz creates a toxic Community also
out of shocked Pikachu face when
interacting with the community yeah I
mean that right that's what happened
mm-hmm
and yeah yeah
that person might not even be
criticizing as much as just meming on
them right it's I like how he plays
moral High Ground now after saying the
n-word for five years straight on the
internet even made a speech about why he
thinks it's saying okay but so so what
is he supposed to do there's no High
Ground
like this is the only argument like that
that's what he said that's his point
right what is it that you want him to do
not change
do you want him to keep saying the n
word like what is it you want he is he's
changed and learned
and is growing and now he's also saying
what he did was not okay you know and
he's taking the videos down
what we really need is an apology rating
from that guy what's that guy uh Seattle
psychology in Seattle he does apology
ratings
you know he rated my apology to cutie
Cinderella a perfect score I didn't
really he said he had never seen an
apology that good before whoa yeah that
quick he said is that good oh that good
he said this might be the best
influencer apology I've ever seen wow
did you know that about me no I didn't
know I mean I don't think you I don't
think you're a champ yeah I don't think
you're supposed to feel that like like I
feel so accomplished I've done such a
perfect apology so I almost am glad that
it happened
psychology in Seattle yes I'm just
kidding I'm making a joke here but yeah
he did give me a perfect score so shout
out
that was one of my best apologies but I
tell you what man um
when it comes to apologizing I'll tell
you man I stick The Landing brother
that's right
um sorry
so let me pull up this Charlie video or
actually no I don't need to pull up The
Charlie video but I just wanted to say
that the the
he's like the biggest voice in the com
Community uh
commentary Community right now so what
he says is consequential
you know
and his basically his take and you guys
can correct me if I'm wrong to kind of
try to uh distill it
was that he doesn't think the content
was that bad and he didn't need to
apologize
um he does qualify by saying he he puts
it in the time frame of like it's 2016.
everybody was making content like that
and he even says
um
you could feel like it wasn't okay then
and that's a separate conversation and
you can feel that way but the vast
majority of people watching YouTube
didn't have a problem with it back then
and idubbbz says it went beyond being
edgy it was cruel and Charlie disagrees
with that he doesn't really think it was
cruel and or or problematic to apologize
which is weird I mean the thing is that
Ian knows best what their reaction was
to his videos
so if he says that it was cruel and bad
this is based on his behavior or his
interaction with people his experience
he's the one that's gonna know best yeah
I think he did think it was problematic
it was just
I don't think it was his place to talk
about the degree at which it was
problematic or the degree at which the
apology
you know it wasn't meant for him like I
said guys frankly I mean
my credit what
I I frankly disagree that uh
with him saying it wasn't cruel I mean
at least at least in the example of the
Tana one I mean that was the point right
that was the point it was cruel yeah I
mean uh she was she was a young girl and
this was this guy in his mid to late 20s
and and what he did to her was pretty
[__] up and I think acknowledging that
and apologizing for it is totally fine
and within it's cool yeah and tana is a
good person she's not you know I mean
like we've all done dumb [__] so yeah
you know she's was so young at the time
I mean she's so young it's hard to
forget how young she was was she
probably 18 at the time of the of his
content cough
maybe even younger and she she just made
like one tweet at him about how
um
I don't like your use of the n-word
and then he turned it into this whole
Odyssey about [__] ruining her life
and at the time we all thought it was
funny and awesome and [__] but like yeah
I think it's cool that he's apologized
to her and clearly her reaction on
Twitter shows how much it did affect her
she told us when she came on the show I
mean you could tell that she was it
[__] her up that whole thing yeah dude
she was on the receiving end of so much
[__] hate you can't even imagine
because I don't know how many views that
video had but tens of millions certainly
so it's a teenage girl it's like damn
yeah that's rough she was 19 I believe
at the time yeah she's still so young
it's crazy
um but but I think it's great
and valid you know but there it is
um
guys this was about as as offensive as a
hot dog with two with just mustard and
no ketchup I mean it was pretty
offensive but like not that offensive
you could still eat the hot dog you
don't need to return it or throw it out
it was like that
being said he is my boy because I met
him and that's all that I need to oh you
guys are dogs yeah oh yeah you guys are
like best friends basically yeah you met
him that one time
this comment is exactly how I feel
peanut butter and fika said Charlie
makes the same mistake Ian is trying to
apologize for consideration of people on
the receiving end of Ian's views he's
he's worrying about the fans reaction to
his reaction
right yes you know
guys today I'm going to talk about Ian's
apology which is about as spot on as
when I take a [__] on the wall at a
bullseye and it triples down onto
another little rat trap and then the rat
comes and tries to eat the feces
anyone else you got a good one Dan
I will never apologize for any of my
confidence
pipe cleaner and instead of it being if
I'm not looking at you crystals it would
be like razor wire and I would take that
pipe cleaner I'd stick it up my nose I
really thought of my nostrils so hard
that it combines into one nostril just
like a cokehead and then it's just
bleeding and I'm just breathing in and
out blood Non-Stop
okay
sorry for you once I get going on today
guys I'm gonna watch Ian's apology which
is about as pleasant as a cactus being
shoved up my ass and then the I'm gonna
and then I paint a picture with the
blood coming from my anus
and call it art I'm gonna go to the
bathroom my neck brace is here you guys
hey so I don't know I feel like I have
let's see have I fully flushed this out
I don't want to leave anything unsaid
uh
I believe so
unless
I just hope I
and one thing Charlie was saying in his
video that I uh something that I agree
with uh agree with uh to an extent is
that I hope
I hope he feels like
he can just move on and start making the
content that he wants to make now
because that was one aspect of what
Charlie was saying when he was saying oh
he doesn't need to apologize if you want
to make different content that's great
and go ahead and just do it but you
don't need to apologize for your old
content I don't agree with that half of
it well he doesn't need to apologize but
like that's he wants to right because
he's going through something important
uh for his it's like it's so okay
whatever right yeah but I do hope that
Ian feels that you know he can actually
but you know he can stop addressing it
he's done haters like I hope he can just
be done with those people and just
understand he's not going to win them
back over and that's fine yeah he's done
he can move on now
but um it's funny because Ian's content
before all the edgy [__] he was like
people loved his stuff where it was just
like gross food reviews but there was
nothing problematic about that stuff
yeah you know sewer pickles I did one
with them about the chicken
we did one about like uh
I forget what it was where we were
wrestling and [__] it's been so long
but there it is all right so we have PMP
on the line we do America's favorite
attorney let's go
oh wait let me get my neck brace on
before he calls in yeah actually that's
good
thank you girl you're welcome you should
ask you should ask him if he's ever had
a client put one of those on too good
[__] question dude the real shame is
the juice the jury a little bit and I
hope this works we should have used this
for click bait but it happened right
before the show actually it does it's
nice
in a [__] up way yeah all right I'm
gonna bring him in yeah
looks good too let's go
that looks good you like it yeah
like elongating you're giving neck oh
we're in what's up we're in my boy sorry
for the delay I need to put my volume up
while I'm doing work just sitting here
and
you know all right here we are David as
I sit here before you with a neck brace
have you ever instructed um a client to
wear one of these
[Laughter]
let's go of my expertise I I have
definitely had clients go to doctors who
recommended that
so you wouldn't recommend it but you
know a guy you know right
all I could do is my best and if someone
needs help seeing a doctor I can point
them dude you're awesome
you truly are America's uh favorite
attorney
thank you so the reason I actually
wanted to talk to you is first of all to
tell this incredible story and to thank
you personally our nanny who works for
us was was in this crazy situation where
she has her her room not roommate but
housemate they were sharing an apartment
together the guy
just went he I guess started doing drugs
and just went had like a whole episode
and he was like threatening her moving
people in doing all kinds of crazy [__]
it was a month-to-month lease and she
wanted she was scared so I said just
leave dude don't be there anymore
because you know we've seen the she was
cared for her safety I said get out now
and we'll deal with the consequences of
that so she moved out and the
um
the landlords were like no you're you're
still there your name's on the contract
you're you're liable for all this [__]
do I have that right David
it was so bad and by the way I'm sorry
for the echo I just moved into this
brand new office and it's all wood
you're good you're moving up fancy fans
upgrade look at that yeah can I see out
the window you got a view wait
like a nice view then we're talking
let's see what I got Beverly Drive out
here okay not exactly a view but uh it's
not not that great but it's a gloomy day
out here but
good lighting
yeah yeah it's nice thank you yes all
right so
the case for your Nanny was crazy we had
the shadiest landlords I've ever seen
their Law Firm was so bad I don't even
do landlord tenant law I just wanted to
help you guys out because I wanted to
help you guys out
and at first
I try to find a lawyer that actually
does landlord tenant law to help her out
and no one wanted a house so yeah and I
I had done my own investigating and
looking for an attorney to help her and
nobody wanted to [__] help and so I
turned to David as a as a Act of
desperation because I knew he was a
scrappy [__] and he would just
get in there and [__] [__] up and David
went out there he didn't charge us he
didn't charge my nanny and I gotta say
David saved the day he did it that's
right
amen and he got that he got her off the
[__] lease it was amazing he actually
did she was so stressed during the whole
time and I've never seen her like that
and so you really saved the day can I
tell you guys something
I'm a member of this Facebook group for
lawyers okay and there's thousands of
lawyers in here and they all ask for
legal advice or ask for referrals for
other lawyers
and you know I asked like hey this is a
situation I'm in are there any lawyers
in here do you recommend anyone that can
help
and everyone said the name of this one
lawyer hey come chime in she chimed in
and apparently she's like one of the
greatest tenant lawyers in L.A hmm
and her answer is oh yeah you don't have
a case because XYZ and oh yeah this is
it's not a case so you know no one can
really help this person Booyah answered
the question correctly I'm like what's
wrong with you
it didn't make sense I got I got a lot
of that too where it's like well no it's
her fault because she's on the lease but
that didn't make sense at all because
the guy's threatening her she's supposed
to stay there and like put and risk
bodily harm sorry all right so here's
yeah yeah right here's the law okay
technically yeah she was on the hook
because they both signed the lease and
she wasn't allowed to just leave while
he's there
and they were not dating they didn't
have a dating relationship that would
have made things a lot easier to get out
because she could have claimed domestic
violence so right
this is how Shady the property manager
was
this guy went crazy and was even
threatening the property manager they
knew he was on him he asked your Nanny
hey can you come to the police with me
to report this guy and she said yeah of
course I'll come to the police with you
anything to help you guys I'm a great
tenant and she goes to the police and
reports the guy with manager right there
and
and they don't give her any credit for
that
and so the law says
you could you can get out of your lease
if you have a restraining order against
your roommate
obviously she doesn't want to get a
restraining order against some guy
because that's going to rile him up and
make him go crazier
or I didn't even know if she had cause
for a restraining order technically
right
but I don't know if she even had a cause
for that I don't know how it works but
you know arguably it's much tougher if
you never had a dating relationship with
someone it gets complex but if you've
ever dated someone
uh then you get a domestic violence
restraining order which you only need to
show more likely than not
that you needed it
um and that's much easier and hearsay is
admissible as evidence but since they
didn't have a dating relationship you
would need to prove it by clear and
convincing evidence and hearsay is not
admissible so it becomes tough
and if you lose these if you lose a
request for a restraining order
the prevailing party is allowed their
attorney's fees oh yeah that's tough
It's tall and if she wasn't living there
anymore a judge might not have even
granted it for that purpose so
the next the next thing you could do is
show a police report that based on the
police report it evidences that you're a
victim of domestic violence and then we
run into the same problem because this
was not domestic violence because they
never had a dating relationship just
being a roommate wasn't enough
uh we showed the police report and they
said yeah no this isn't Gonna Fly and
I've consulted with a lot of these
attorneys I have friends that that do
landlord tenant law none of them wanted
to jump in on this and they're all
telling me yeah yeah they're right
they're right and that's that's the
point just to interject I offered them
two thousand dollars I said I'll pay you
guys two grand just to drop it and we
can all part ways amicably and they said
they told us to [__] off right
we offered them 2 000 bucks they said no
and I'm like what the hell do they want
what they want they want like six
thousand dollars or something yeah I
mean it was like has no money
and is a victim anyway
uh so there's one last option that we
explored and that's if you have a third
party professional
write a report uh
write a report saying that she's truly a
victim of these certain types of crimes
and she has uh
like a mental issue because of it
then then that can fly so there is a PHD
psychologist
that I use sometimes in my cases
um she's very good
and so I thought okay great let's uh I
mean I've never done one of these and
I'm sure she's this expert witness has
never done one of these situations so I
talked to her I emailed her all the law
what we need specifically
uh and had your Nanny meet with her and
she wrote a beautiful report
uh that saying that she's a victim of
stalking
and this gets complex because civil
stocking different from Criminal
stalking civil stalking is just anyone
that did anything to harass a person
more than once it's so broad so so Broad
that it was enough and the the other
brilliant play that we did we learned
from
the only person we could get advice from
um my personal attorney recommended we
contact an organization but they only
help like low-income people and they
were all like you make too much money we
can't talk to you but we managed to get
one of these like beautiful kind-hearted
people that are just helping you know
doing like Pro or I don't know if it's
pro bono but like deeply discounted work
for people who are being harassed by
their landlords she said
go to the courthouse right now before
it's too late because she had been
served like three weeks ago and the time
was ticking she said go to the
courthouse and request a jury trial
because when a tenant gets sued by a
landlord
they have to pay for all the costs
associated with that trial so so she's
like do that and immediately it won't be
worth it for them so Abby got down there
was able to change it to a jury trial
and that one trick is pro is like so
powerful because it's going to cost them
what like 10 grand or something at least
to to go through that trial
yeah in my last email to them
I sent them the psychologist report
and I I sent you my email but I said
something like hey I
uh here is this report I think this
should be enough and I want you to know
uh if you're going to email me saying
that this isn't enough what is going to
happen after that is that I'm going to
formally substitute into the case as the
attorney and we will proceed with the
jury trial that's what's up I think you
have a nice day yeah
and you know maybe a week later they got
back to me and said okay we're dismissed
so they so David did The Impossible and
I just want to thank you so much like
yeah can you talk we talk on the show
but David swooped into my life yeah
helped me with the situation that seemed
almost uh you know helpless I can't
emphasize enough how I have never seen
her like that she was so stressed every
day she just didn't know what was gonna
happen well the guy's still there
and this guy used to be her friend it's
such a weird situation to begin with
right yeah it's not fair to her you know
on so many levels but so the guy is
still there he's just still squatting
what and he's just squatting yeah he's
just squatting because the tenants I
don't think he's even paying the rent
he's not paying the rent he's still
living there with a bunch of like
addicts they just do drugs there it's
like you know what actually now that
she's been removed from the situation
good stay there [__] those landlords
that's 100 hard to attitude too I was
like enjoy the [__] this is what you
get enjoy it now that we're talking
about I'm thinking I might send some
more clients out there
I know today
oh my God yeah but and and David was so
available and you were so there and
you're just the man dude thank you so
much yeah of course I'm just happy that
we got the W at the end let
on your end
things have been so damn busy
um I have had
10 criminal cases this week just between
Monday and today in core depositions all
of Monday deposition today after court
uh so
you know you guys wanted me to come in I
think on Monday I was it was too busy
but you know thank God honestly we're
busy we're kicking ass we're settling
big civil cases helping out a lot of
people with DUIs
it's been great let me see the pup
behind you you got a dog behind you
she's not here today but her bed is here
the toy tricked everybody in the
audience our audience was all asking if
we could see the dog there was that one
video we watched recently where you he
wouldn't say how [__] up the crime was
right have we ever asked David about
that you pulled that up yeah yeah there
was one recently I don't know if you saw
us talk about it but we could tell that
dude [__] up and it was one of the
only ones where you don't say what he
did so I was like yo this guy must
really right outside Rancho Cucamonga
courthouse where we scored big uh at the
outset of this case is really tough I'll
tell you I have multiple victims we had
multiple yeah one thing we noticed the
first time watching this we might
appreciate is just how big your eyes get
when you talk about how bad is crying
which is really tough I'll tell you we
had multiple victims we had hey let me
go back go back more yeah yeah here it
is Cucamonga courthouse where we scored
big uh at the outset
that was it that was a tough one for you
David I could tell
at the outset of this case is really
tough I'll tell you we had multiple
victims we had multiple charges we had a
lot of jail on the line but I'm proud to
announce that today we took a good deal
no jail and this is going to be off his
record in no time how do you feel wow go
great you got me off so what did he do
can you say or what was that yeah I can
say oh he can say okay yeah what didn't
he do right right
and honestly I think I don't know if I
forgot to say what they were during the
video or if I just felt like damn is he
gonna be really embarrassed because it
would be bad it was well now let's do it
in front of 40 000 people
it was a DUI started off as a DUI okay
he's drunk and high
enough weed
yeah
so I mean does that count would be yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but it definitely counts I mean again
high is pretty deadly combo so
he he crashes into a car that then
crashes into another car in front of it
and he he's like oh [__]
um the guy in the in the last car that
gets hit isn't
off-duty police officer oh boy he gets
out of the car and he walks up to my
client's door and starts cussing him out
and my client's like trying to explain
himself like I'm sorry or whatever
and
by the way this is all alleged I mean I
wasn't there but yeah alleged right yeah
allegedly
the off-duty officer ticks out and gone
whoa right what what the [__] my client
freaks out
reverses and gets the hell out of there
and and he like goes away a few blocks
you know left right left right whatever
it is that's good though that's your
advice right to drunk drivers leave the
scene
he followed your advice
not my advice but I've seen it before
with good outcomes right work for other
people
uh so it's off duty officer comes with
his car and like Parks like sideways so
my client can't leave this
they get out of the car off duty officer
beats the [__] out of my client yo what
the [__]
the police bro
um allegedly
allegedly my client fought back and and
hit him first whatever it is so they
charge him for battery for that so it
was it was DUI it was hit and run it was
battery
and they found a bottle of Jack Daniels
uh that was allegedly thrown into a
neighbor's property he found a half
birth joint on the uh on the floor where
you know the driver's floor my client's
car
uh and it was tough man
they're really going hard on this guy
in the end he just got a DUI no jail
and um my man had a gun pulled on him I
would run too yeah I would run yeah yeah
that was my argument but I mean dear
look they're alleging all sorts of [__]
that was bad for us but it's it's fine
like Beyond A Reasonable Doubt is such a
good tool
it's what it is
I mean that that's what the law is right
there gotta be Beyond a reasonable doubt
that's what it is that's what it is if
there's any doubt
that's what it is let's go
it doesn't take much for something to be
reasonable reasonable yeah right think
unreasonable and just add like just go a
little bit this way and then you're
there right that's it was you driving
was he drunk
maybe the bottle
maybe the bottle found in his car was uh
what flew into it when he crashed
it was from maybe uh the car behind it
the bottle was found in a yard that
wasn't his yeah you know it's just some
The Joint they found in his car
my client went never waste weed like
that right these finishes
he's never left the half yeah no never
never
and I have 10 Witnesses who will come to
trial to testify that kind of thing
this whole blood rotation will attest to
this is this his first DUI
yeah that was is does he have a criminal
record
oh no he doesn't well I'm glad he's back
on the road let's go I'm glad he's back
out there brother yeah yeah he's good
yeah
yeah so that was a that was a good one I
can see why your eyes went real wide
though that was that was how much jail
time was he facing down 90
whoa whoa you got that [__] for
nine years that's crazy
[Music]
oh 90 days
but I want you to know that was not L.A
County
once you leave L.A
you're doing it the time
right San Bernardino right overcrowding
so let's say I get 30 days jail
you're probably gonna be out in a date
or two
it's a good deal
here's another dude uh that you helped
out second DUI
let's go and right side of court with my
client we absolutely crushed his case
look this was a second time DUI yeah he
was leaving the Rufus do Soul concert at
the Hollywood Bowl had some drinks had a
dirty dog a delicious Glizzy he was
having a good ass time there oh it
sounds cool I was at that concert too
and I also had a dirty dog you know how
good of a time that guy had Rufus The
Soul Man they get you partying
uh allegedly he got behind the wheel and
crashed into another car with an angry
person in it who called the police now I
mean what's it the angry bird the Angry
Bird who cares who cares three before
the accident he was angry before the
accident there's such oh
uh-huh it was at issue whether or not he
was really the driver or if it was his
girlfriend driving Reasonable Doubt
police never even asked him
he drove his own car and he would just
stand
ing the police doing the field
s never even asked him and the other
driver his statement was was kind of
iffy too so the prosecutors really gave
us a hard time on this case they wrote a
three-page internal memo on this case
and ultimately sided with us and now
he's gonna only get a reckless driving
all right the DUI charges dismissed and
you're only getting a reckless driving
one year of probation instead of three
year a set of five years that they
wanted him to have because it was the
second time DUI
0.23 BAC very high blood alcohol content
with Collision
the end of the day they couldn't really
really prove it 100 it was too risky if
they went to trial they probably you
know they could have you know there's a
roll of the dice so that's why it seems
like uh
he probably did that [__]
it was tough man yeah roll the dice you
know so what was the statement of the of
the other party that was iffy
he said
in a DUI investigation the police have
to
they have to write down the police
report whether this person really was
behind the wheel driving okay because
whether he's driving is an element of
The Chronic
and they kind of took it for granted
here
but so they didn't ask my client which
is weird because like why would you ask
someone if he drove his own car okay
well he had a passengers because it was
so obvious he was driving right yeah but
what they wrote in the report was they
talked to the other guy the driver of
the other car and that guy said he saw
my client exiting the car from the
driver's side door
really
yeah
so that was their only only basis for
him being the driver
so we turned around I mean that's pretty
good that's pretty good though hold on
hold on
I don't deny
I didn't even deny that my client was
seen exiting the driver's side door
right
we admit that fact we love that fact it
is true and that's why we admitted the
problem is this
my client got out of the passenger side
door his girlfriend gets out of the car
she's freaking out
he gets into the driver's side to move
the car but the other driver said no no
don't move the car just let the police
come and so my client got out of the
driver's side never drove without ever
moving the car even an inch that's what
happened
Reasonable Doubt my friend yeah
Legend
you guys better be calling David
that's a tough one honestly that's a
really tough one like you anyone who
calls me saying this and calls me hey I
have a case like that do not expect your
case to end up that way but again it's a
roll of the dice all right
uh here's one more the D you do magic
for the DUI community
all right
no one no one thinks it's interesting on
the internet dude I love this [__] this
is [__] amazing you're like a hero in
the DUI community
[Laughter]
you know they probably the DUI Community
probably has pictures of like the patron
saint of drunk driving the Mothers
Against Drunk Driving have pictures in
me too that's true yeah yeah here's one
more
another DUI dismissed I'm with my great
client here he was charged with a DUI uh
it was really late at night past 3 A.M
he was involved in a car crash it wasn't
his fault okay
hey David I believe you
said they could not afford getting a DUI
on his record otherwise he becomes
deportable
the DA's office fought us a lot on this
case I got into an argument with the D.A
on the record about a month ago what was
that about
uh so
the thing is it
it's
criminal the practice of criminal law
requires us to negotiate the attorneys
have to negotiate
a problem that happens at a lot of
courthouses is that the DA's office
just
okay how do I put this
DA's are notorious for never checking
their emails Never Falling Back people
if you leave them a voicemail never even
answering the phone in the first place
because they're in court all day it's
really tough to get a hold of these
people
um and I don't know why that is when I
was a prosecutor I mean I get it like
who's really emailing you you don't even
have any real clients your client is the
the government
uh so I've been trying to negotiate this
case for some time
and I I get crickets back
finally I get through to the prosecutor
and
they sent me an email back saying no we
can't give you a deal that you're
looking for and it's just disregarding
my entire letter that I sent I wrote I
drafted a nice letter to them
outlining the facts of the case and why
we should it should be resolved this way
and everything
uh and they say no your client has such
a long rap sheet he has like 30 prior
conditions for all these types of things
just last year he was convicted of
receiving stolen uh you know stolen
property and burglary wait is that all
is that is that all true
no oh okay
look my client's not a citizen so
it's it gets kind of complicated but
they
they give you look when you go to court
the DA's as part of the initial
Discovery like just the police report uh
they also give you your criminal record
for your fly
his criminal record was a fat stack of
papers but when you look at when you
look at the names of the people who are
convicted of these crimes none of them
were his name hmm
I'm like what the hell is political air
yeah that and also someone stole his ID
oh [__] and every time they get arrested
they use his name wow but then they
found out who it really was so my client
really never got in trouble for that but
when she gave she gave me a case number
yeah last last year in Glendale
courthouse he was just convicted of
burglary I'm like please just put in
that case number and look what name
comes up steal your ID
and so you had a hard time just getting
them to do that basic fact check
yeah
I send an email I'm like listen just
just put in that case number and reread
this whole thing like you got this all
wrong
no I just get crickets another email
crickets another email crickets calling
them leaving answers like voicemail
crickets so we get to court
and
I mean
thank you so much I was just pissed at
this point you know what I mean like
come on so I tell the judge I tell the
judge your honor
I need the Court's intervention here I'm
so sorry to bring this up but I need the
court to help me out because I just
don't know what else I can do here I can
the court please order this D.A to talk
to me because I have sent them an email
on on so and so day at so and so time
didn't receive anything back another
email so and so date so-and-so a time
another email I called this that this is
the situation that's happening
this D A blew upon and was so upset and
embarrassed because they're in this
courtroom all the time with this judge
and and they go on a 15-minute tirade
against me this was unprofessional he
could have brought this to my attention
sooner
and I was waiting for them to stop at
the very end I'm like your honor yeah I
did bring it up to them sooner on this
date and time on this date yeah
wow so so you you
God bless you man welcome to the police
am I right [__] the D.A [__] the police
no they do well it depends on which
studio some days are no they're cool I
mean they they called me back and I said
listen I'm sorry for having said that to
the judge you know I I just desperately
wanted you guys to resolve this case
with me I apologize for that and and
they apologized also and and now we're
cool and and then and then they they
start sending me the police reports for
that ID theft guy and and they're like
hey next time this guy screws your
client over make sure he has these on
his records
did the judge come make a decision did
did the judge rule on your behalf that
they have to talk to you what happened
order a VA to talk to me or anything I
did that for theatrics that's awesome
but the judge did tell them
talk to council and and that's I got
what I wanted
there it is David does what it takes
people are saying have you considered
this first slogan better dial Dave
you're the real deal
well if I use that I hope none of your
fans come after me for uh copyright or
anything I can't promise I mean I won't
but uh hey if they're maybe they're
gonna find another Dave to represent
them and then you're in real trouble
coming as Scrappy as you all right uh
thanks for calling always a pleasure to
hear from you my friends let's go thank
you for all your help and uh
yo y'all better be dialing Dave
thank you guys always a pleasure being
here and uh I'll see you soon thank you
talk to you soon
gotta love him
you know that you know
here's two people you want in your life
that are a little bit Shady
all right I don't know Shady let's say
morally ambiguous
your lawyer and you're creative
they're creative
creatives and I want shady ass
[__] for my lawyer and my
accountant that's it
that's what I'm talking about
he's actually incredible though he is
insanely good at his job that dude gets
dubs all day you know you had told me
that he had helped out your nanny I I
guess I didn't realize that he did pro
bono yeah yeah I mean I offered to pay
him but he was just hooked us up what a
guy yeah
[Music]
it was really nice man he really helped
us out
oh so okay fun times do you take off the
neck brace you might need it
I actually feel okay it feels a little
better now okay the neck brace was
starting to annoy me more than
the pain Okay so we've got the idubbbz
out of the way let's do the uh the
PowerPoint hey girl
so this one's I don't know anything
about this one but it sounds pretty
pretty interesting I think this is crazy
I don't know anything about this one
either I had excited literally anyone
talking about it I saw Jesse and Lily
were talking about it on do we know them
that was it that's all I saw okay so
there's a YouTube well you explain it
right so right go through it no I'll
tell you I'll take you through the story
yeah absolutely okay so we have a
YouTuber a dubs which is kind of funny
because we have idubbbz and a dubs yeah
the dubs episode when I saw the title I
was wondering if this was a joke or
something I didn't know yeah no it's
it's
it's real all right so girl do I join a
quote the mysterious disappearance of
Axel Weiss
a little true crime-ish Alex sure if you
want to say it but her name is Alex not
Axel is that what he said yeah maybe
Alex just a quick correction um yeah
yeah I could see it well if just Alex
yeah if the Y and L were Reserve reverse
it might be 100
Axel maybe maybe all right let's go so
here she is go ahead Okay so girl do I
join a cult the mysterious disappearance
of Alex Weiss our first player this is
Alex Weiss she's a YouTuber
um if you flip to the next slide her um
main series was a fake Uber prank she
was like a fake Uber driver she was
really good friends with Gen X pen if
you remember who that is
um they had a series or she had a series
on her Channel called revealing your
secrets and um which is later what
branched into what the name of her
podcast was but um that's our first
player okay but there's good tea
actually this Reveal Your Secrets I lost
my virginity to my sister
I ate cat poop and liked it
4.7 mil baby what's your argument
you know lose it with someone you trust
they always say
all right and
layer is Colts like the concept as a
whole
um that's our friend Jared on the right
is he involved or just he's
representative Colts the concept as a
whole okay okay like I think yeah
Ayahuasca is um our third player I
didn't know that's even what it looks
like
it's just like a root what is Ayahuasca
right well yeah it I don't think this is
like prepared because ultimately it's a
it's like a drink stew yeah okay it's a
drink have you tried it Dan no no uh
Bradley Martin offered to uh hook us up
though oh yeah I forgot about his
Ayahuasca yeah yeah we uh gained the
power of empathy
from Ayahuasca I love them man it's like
they're not they can't talk to a
therapist because that's gay so they
just have to take Ayahuasca and hope
that that like does something well in
his case it sounded like it did yeah
it's a positive so yeah it did that's
nice
yeah he had a really positive experience
with it probably not her though of where
this is going
up the story last player this is Tessa
the girl we met while doing Ayahuasca
okay yes okay
Ayahuasca is a type of Brew made from
ingredients with hallucinogenic
properties though some claim it can
benefit brain health well-being it is
also associated with several potential
risks what drug is it well we're about
to find out about those risks
um it's like I would describe it's like
acid but more spiritual by the way
people describe it I don't know or
mushrooms
there it is
all right so next slide YouTuber to
podcaster pipeline she was following the
pattern started a podcast to June summer
um it was called revealing your secrets
with Alex Weiss
very normal progression in terms of
YouTuber to podcaster okay we're on
track and fairly big she had what like
two million subs or something what is it
yeah 1.7 that's you know that's
respectable for sure yes so her final
episode of the podcast it was not
announced that it would be the final
episode
um was December 16 2022 with guest Carly
and Aaron from the blogs they were from
the blog Squad before
um it was them with her
it was a normal episode
but something interesting happened
during that episode
if we go to the next slide yes
so oh Alex brings up that she was a
coach by the cult and this was our last
episode before we we went dark for a
long time oh okay so should I would just
watch this time yeah
um this has nothing to do with you but
it's something that happened to me
yesterday and I just want to talk about
it okay I escaped a cult yesterday
a cult
Ure in L.A I don't well first off I'm
not sure the name of it um the
information I do have I'm like nervous
to even say it oh my God a great tea so
I I went on Meetup
um to find a group to meditate with
because I've been meditating a lot
lately that's where you fall into a call
so yesterday I was uh pulled off the
street and kidnapped in a windowless van
um
spill the tea girl well that reminds me
of can you pull up that tweet from Hank
uh green
yeah he sadly uh shared that he was
diagnosed
with cancer which is horrible I mean I
feel so bad it is luckily as he
explained one of the most treatable
forms of cancer was like 90 percent
survival rate long-term survival rate
but anyway as of course it's terrifying
to be yeah oh no it was yeah oh oh no
why did he do that
oh do we have a I sent this did I send a
screenshot maybe I'll go look through it
so good it's so good a drama alert
keemstar tweets out
from the drama account Hank Green
diagnosed with cancer and then Hank
Green quote tweeted and said drama
I'm drunk like his [__] cancer
diagnosis hashtag drum alert so funny
thank you okay so here it is anyway
I would love like a spiritual community
going in the direction of a club yeah so
I um signed up for this meditation I go
to somewhere in Pasadena that's like in
the middle of nowhere it's um this like
non-secular religious
um compound like it's literally a
compound you know there are buildings
it's like in nature whatever I noticed
the second I drive onto the property my
music stops playing on my phone and I
look at my phone and I have no service
oh yeah girl turn around but I didn't no
I always like you know you have to know
I knew but but do you ever just kind of
yeah you just want to just explore a
little bit and I made it all the way it
drove a while to get there it was like a
40 minute drive the way that anyway this
so story
if we want to cap that right now it ends
with people were very nice it was fun
um I talked to some people and they
invited me to a potluck and I kind of
want to go so wait I wonder why she
framed it like I escaped a cold I think
it's the click bait of it but then it's
also the self-awareness which is
interesting considering what happens
afterward but um yeah I think it's
self-awareness humor and also being
interested in the Cults so so she she
went on to describe actually they're
awesome and she gonna do a potluck with
them she was like they were they were
really nice and they invited me to a
potluck did you describe what's cultish
about them
compound now you'll there's a little bit
well we'll learn a lot more vitamins
what she's interested potluck it was
only Kool-Aid though yeah I found that
to be a little weird everyone was
wearing Nikes yeah someone had grapes
someone brought Cherry here's the Tweet
it's uh Hank Green was diagnosed with
cancer
it's just him it's like it's just the
fact that it's a drama alert yeah like
drama you made the news you made the
news
that's so true right I'm right on dry
mode drama alert I don't know if people
even still remember but whenever
keemstar we talk about you in his
episodes you would tweet at you you made
the news yeah right
okay interesting we then go dark for
four and a half months
everywhere wow
no Twitter
nothing that's crazy so wow yep like in
March this article came out this is
before she came back if you go to the
next uh slide a fan posted this Tick
Tock which did gain traction which
caused people to realize that she had
been gone for so long and people were
connecting the dogs they're like this is
a cool thing YouTube okay so yeah I see
this got a lot of uh likes engagement
here let's check it out
from
brigh gold rygold
there's this YouTuber and podcaster I've
been listening to that said they were
going to go meet up with a cult and then
dropped off the face of the Earth and
nobody's talking about it and they're
super popular
so it's Alex Weiss this is the podcast
I've been listening to and I only
noticed because I went to go listen to
the newest episode because I had been a
while and there was no new uploads
this is the last episode she posted it
was December 16th and this is where she
mentions like going and meeting up with
like a cult for lunch or something like
that
so then I took to her Instagram and no
new post there either but if you look in
the comments everybody seems you know
people are worried I'm worried like I'm
just like let me read this comment I'm
genuinely concerned for Alex I've been
worried since she first mentioned the
potluck on the podcast I think about her
going Mia multiple times a day it's just
really uneases me knowing she went to it
even though she herself had bad vibes I
wish someone could let us know she's
okay interesting because she's clearly
if she's
anywhere and okay seeing this feedback
of people being worried about her one
would think well I don't know
if you know if they like they're like
put your phone away yeah I'm assuming if
you were to assume that she's fine you
know what I mean she's not in a call and
she's fine then she's going to have seen
all this yes yes I'm not gonna tell you
yet okay if she's seen it I'm fine
people
and this is just kind of odd like don't
you think this is kind of odd
and she has like one like
1.73 big number big number followers and
no one I feel like no one's talking
about this and she hasn't posted on
YouTube nothing
what's up what's up can some tick tocks
loose do their Tick Tock thing
I'm not a sleuth
so but I just wanna I wanna know what's
up okay me too yeah yes a damn so fans
are worried yeah next okay let me pop
back here
fans are worried and we're back with a
new video two weeks ago after four and a
half months of not posting anything just
happened two weeks ago two weeks ago she
posted revealing my secret talking about
the cult and she did
yeah click that
I have all the good time stamps don't
worry this tea is hot to just talk this
through with a friend I left hey dude
did you hear a second plane hit the
World Trade Center T girl tell me drum
alert
a famous photo of uh them whispering in
George W Bush's uh here that was George
Bush's response he's like tea yeah gag
awesome roll it to go and kind of fall
off the face of the Earth there was a
rumor that began to circulate that I
joined a cult
and I did
whoa yeah so there's that clip I have
everything else if you want to go to the
next slide okay you have it all time
stamped so this is all I need to watch
on this yep you don't have to keep
watching I just have all my favorite
lines okay
so the next thing she said that I
thought was hilarious if you are we on
it so happens the night before I had a
running with a cult I went on Meetup I
went to a meditation thing it was culty
they invited me to a potluck and I
wanted to go just for shits and giggles
so I told
the story yeah for the story for the bit
so I told that story on the podcast I
escaped a cult yesterday a cult occult
but I also told it fully intentionally
knowing it would be my last episode and
I didn't know when I would post next and
that would sort of like plant a seed for
people to wonder where I was what sorry
it was a bit what that's a little bit
that's a little crazy yeah you're not
really thinking about your audience
you don't believe her she did it what do
you mean I don't believe that she did
that by Design oh you don't think that
yeah you think she's taking credit now
she's just trying to stick the land but
even if no but that's getting it's
getting clicks and attention right I
think but even the idea of doing it by a
design is really gross right I agree I
agree but I think
the what I think happened is that she's
just trying to cover up I don't know
what's happened but it seems like she
did get associated with this weird old
people so it's easier for her to be like
oh no this was all I know this was my
game yeah yeah I didn't stop because of
the cult yeah right yeah because I doubt
like who would do that who would do that
just disappear for three and a half
months without saying anything four and
a half four and a half even longer yeah
I'm sorry I don't buy that yeah
she basically says she didn't expect
people to be as worried as they were
okay hold on let me watch a little bit
more because she goes on to say it's
funny I escaped the cult yesterday a
cult occult but I also told it fully
intentionally knowing it would be my
last episode and I didn't know when I
would post next and that would sort of
like plant a seed for people to wonder
where I was yeah it was a bit
it's funny what's funny
what's funny about missing I feel like
and make him feel a little worried about
where you are that's funny well also
assuming what she's saying is true
assuming she's totally fine
then she gonna see the genuine concern
people are having and then it's funny I
should say something you know but no
right she's in a quote but what I did
not expect was that it would mean people
were going to be worried about me I
didn't like maliciously want people to
all right so next one didn't expect
right should I when she wanted to plant
the seed for people to wonder where she
was she did no worried just wonder just
wonder yeah she's missing but you know
what when have we ever whenever she's
back ready when have we ever heard of
missing young women going wrong
so next one yep okay
the next one
is that oh yes so basically she says
there's no way to understand what
went on there yeah how it changed us and
changed us this really does sound like a
cult I was just about to say that's
almost the prerequisite because we're so
passionate about what it's done for us
in our life oh she's one of the cult
members yes she met Tessa doing
Ayahuasca the cult oh God and they
talked the the cult that they're
discussing is a second one that they
seeked out because the one at the
potluck didn't end up working out okay
hold on what yeah it's a different they
wanted us to know as a different group
hold on hold on hold on I have questions
yes has this girl ever been in new
videos before this is a new character
she starts this video by going who the
[__] are you and then she explains that
she had tried to sit down and do the
video a few times but she needed to be
talking to someone that understood
for sure she's lying about her intention
you think it doesn't make any sense
she's like okay well I'm not gonna I'm
gonna go on an Ayahuasca Journey with
some random people and disappear like no
she didn't plan that yeah I don't know
it sounds silly to me that makes sense
she's just trying to cover up you think
I don't know I haven't seen the whole
story that's what I'm feeling lives and
the way that we want to effectively
communicate how much to the core it's
done it does somewhat come off as like
yeah recruitment video it's because if
y'all would just stop talking about like
yeah we're in a cult ha ha ha
like why y'all say that so much talk
about it thing that has changed your
life so fundamentally and like actively
has made your life go from something
that is a struggle to be alive to Life
as a gift and you're grateful and stuff
like that of course you want the people
that you don't even know to find that
answer as well and if that's a cult then
big number followers 100 gifted what the
heck is that our Saudi benefactor yes
sir wow thank you there's another 50.
150 150 good thanks man 100. and thank
you on behalf of all the awesome people
are gonna get all those subbies now
that's freaking awesome
it's being bad feels this good
then I don't want to be good uh whatever
big part of the definition of a cult why
are you so what is she doing I think
that's so interesting
the definition of a cult it kind of
means you're you're you're you're done I
think you're scrambling too deep yeah
you're trying to scramble to prove to us
that whatever you're doing is is fine
but it's fine I'll answer as well
um that's that was the last line I want
you to hear from this slide I do want to
see her Define what a call is okay
yeah it's interesting because a big part
of the definition of a cult is a group
of people with over admiration or
Affinity towards something or someone
and you and I and the people that we met
at this Center yeah have an affinity a
love for Ayahuasca for other the other
plants that we worked with yes and for
the Maestro we worked with yes the
Maestro oh God also crazy how they call
it the center the center like oh
it's a book or something the Maestro
yeah
great it's always got to be some [__]
Maestro Vanguard yep
so he probably [__] them all right I
mean that's how these people always go
that's the end goal literally I don't
think I've ever heard of a cult that
doesn't involve the leader who's always
a man [__] children have a good night
right yes or underage girls it's like
every [__] time it's incredible
yeah Cults historically don't really
work out super well mm-hmm well I don't
know I don't know if you've looked it up
but on Google it says it's just people
who choose
it's just people who love stuff yeah
they're just chilling yeah that's a cult
I'm a cult
all right I guess you all are in a cult
by that definition if y'all love me so
much
she spent 12 days in isolation at the
center
uh that's pretty much that's fantastic
that's what I thought if you want to
click and watch uh
two meals a day we were doing a lot of
fasting yeah but it's also like you're
not really supposed to consume media the
less music and podcasts and content and
even books the better you're trying to
get as quiet as possible okay and then
we also spent time in isolation not
talking to anybody I spent 12 days in
isolation
thank you
or during other periods
there yeah that was I included that to
show you her her living space during
isolation this is very interesting it's
right yeah okay next quote from her is
is really interesting to me on the next
lesson second ceremony she just sucks
like puts her her mouth here sucks in
here and here and then immediately
throws up
and then I get up and I feel different
like like lighter than I've ever felt in
my whole life like she took something
out of me that I didn't even know was
there she purged for me sometimes yes
that's like selfless work three times a
week every week for dozens of people and
new people coming in new energies time
and time and time again she shows up her
dad shows up her children oh my God
yeah the kids are there I told you
someone would be [__] kids dude every
goddamn time with a call yeah I thought
that was extra uh silly to me because
um she said that afterwards she got up
and she felt different and funny enough
that's exactly what my friend said to me
when she was on mushrooms yeah she got
up and she just goes yeah
yeah I feel different standing
so there's this lady He also mentioned
um that they would fast yeah two meals a
day she said and then a lot of calls
like even in the Vanguard guy next year
they oh they kind of get the girls to
lose weight they practice yeah a lot of
them it starts as like oh you gotta
cleanse yourself yeah it's it's a system
of control yes
the Maestro we need to find out who's
this [__] Maestro I know right they
didn't name the place they were talking
about possibly just a heads up I just
we got a uh We've detected copyrighted
audio and video your stream may be
temporarily blocked she's doing that I
it I have the warning it's it just
popped up it's got to be from her
footage right true well I'm not well I'm
obviously gonna I'm talking about this
cult [__] my Astro yeah yeah okay I
have I have these
these uh speech bubbles we can read from
no I'll watch it anymore yeah hell yeah
dude I'm not gonna especially because if
they're trying to keep people from
talking about this then I'm definitely
going to talk about it Maestro ass
[__] so if you go to the next
slide I just noted this this was a quote
that she said one sec I want to watch
this a little more okay just being
around all of these people that are
coming in for healing they are showing
us love they dedicate so much more than
just three nights a week because we're
living on the same grounds as them if
you've got a headache they just whip you
up a little something you drink it and
bad boom one time I had a headache and
she just poured it over my head
for me to feel better talk about the
allegations and ceremonies and this is
some Wild Ones
the fact that she thought she was going
to come out here
and have this conversation and people
not freak out is wild what was her
content before like totally normal silly
yeah she she had a fun little podcast
she brought people on like Vlog Squad
members uh she did the Uber prank thing
like it wasn't it wasn't like this
really
should I read the comments or wait what
do you mean because I want to see what
people are saying but oh yeah that's at
the end okay talk about the allegations
I I heard that leaving the bathroom so I
want to get there oh that was oh that
was
that was way yeah okay
dude they're trying to Kai boss people
talking about this that's wow
that's very interesting maestro
maestro
I noted that she said that her
friendships fell away just like that
after returning what
yeah I came home and that's again
straight cold [__] yes alienation always
felt like I was
still does it feels like I'm like living
in a home that doesn't belong to me
anymore you know friendships that just
fell away like that it's really irony
because I feel connected to everyone and
everything and I feel like I can
tolerate things so easily even if I'm
you know around something that's not
pleasurable but I can't help but to feel
such a disconnect from so many parts of
my life that
that existed before yes so ironic isn't
it you learn that you're connected to
everything and you come back what's up
there a problem
we were hearing the audio but for some
reason the video grows it's just
starting on the power because
irony because I feel connected okay cool
I'll just go back a little bit
so they didn't hear this
I guess not oh
okay is again an adjustment period of
alignment and I think perhaps that's
what you're finding is your challenge
right now yeah that your core has been
realigned yeah and now everything else
has to kind of follow yeah I came home
and it felt like I was
still does it feels like I'm like living
in a home that doesn't belong to me
anymore you know friendships that just
fell away like that it's really irony
because I feel connected to everyone and
everything and I feel like I can
tolerate things so easily even if I'm
you know around something that's not
pleasurable but I can't help but to feel
such a disconnect from the next one she
talks about her parents parts of my life
that oh no that existed before it is so
ironic isn't it you learn that you're
connected to everything and you come
back and you feel disconnected
yeah it's almost like you're not
connected
it's almost like you're in a cult
it's so ironic I feel so connective at
the same time
I've dropped every person in my life
friends family it's just it's weird I
know I'm connected though
I feel this I feel this thank you for
the subs man you guys are thank you guys
so much
uh I think our solid 100
what
500. he's given 500 500 whoa what the
hell 500.
you guys are lucky I'm not backing up
right now you're my ass you're my
Maestro bro
you have like a retreat or a camp or
anything I could come attend uh let's do
it yes okay let's get back to the
PowerPoint then yep all right next she
said her parents were calling her
um
oh wait oh no that one that one I've
never heard stories okay in my life I
know what a portfolio oh my God yeah
people healing Crohn's disease yeah that
didn't happen yeah the next one
they closed the pockets in the in the uh
and the anus or the contestants wait
till the next thing
how did you how did you confirm that
were you guys doing colonoscopies at the
center
holes in their body yeah and yes finding
forgiveness for hearings that are in
their bodies well that's I think that's
what Crohn's maybe she was
that's crazy yeah yeah
regeneration it is crazy I hear it can
uh cure Tourette's too yo where's this
I think we should go
guys I had a silly goofy time with a
cult today
yeah
I've never heard stories like that in my
life I know what a portfolio oh my God
yeah people healing Crohn's disease
holes in their body yeah I think I think
she's describing Crohn's disease yeah I
think that makes sense yeah interesting
I don't know what else no I thought it
was just all holes in bodies close up
the holes all of it my ear piercings
they're just close up the holes people
close up the holes finding forgiveness
for things that are unforgivable
unforgivable things speaking with such
suction and peace after entering things
that were I've never even brushed up
against in my life and seeing again how
much their lives would change and then
the way people also were able to rid
themselves of the shackles of our modern
world was really impressive like for
example you know most people frown
against relationships with adults and
children but like that's just
narrow-mindedness you know our Maestro
taught us that that's that's actually
really good
giving away all their money to not that
you have to do that but to just live in
the jungle and help people is that what
you did you gave all your money to
Maestro how Noble [__] hell lady I
just yeah how'd she gets how did she get
twisted up so fast they caught her so
here right MRI watch I feel like
um it makes sense what you're saying
then obviously she didn't plan any of
the that was just something she was
trying to say to make it seem
intentional yeah who wants me to take
their money Maestro be like and maybe
they even encouraged this video because
it's like people are worrying yeah well
also they thought maybe they could get
some new phone recruitment yeah
recruit I think that's part of why
without it it's weird because some of
the stuff she talks like it's not a sin
to do Ayahuasca and feel like you're
learning stuff it's just that people are
very concerned and you're not being very
forthcoming to your fans about whether
or not you are okay like there are so
many warning signs and this I included
top comments at the end that we can we
can sift through but I don't know
there's no doubt there's no doubt that
she is
she's gone people just want her to be
good I don't think that you can reach
her she's in way too deep now
yeah she's gotta have to hit rock bottom
before she gets out no doubt him like
she this is what's gonna happen she's
going to be alienated from everybody in
her life including her family closest
friends she'll have nobody left she'll
have no money left she'll lose all
prospects future prospects and um career
her career fans she'll be she'll lose
every single [__] thing and then at
that moment
somewhere around there she realized
she needs to escape yeah no doubt
the next so fly is where he talks about
her parents we're able to see the parts
of yourself that other people have
worked on and then it paves a little bit
of the way forward Tiffany what happened
was that I then came to Los Angeles and
I shifted all of my attachment to other
things that I'd let go of onto making
sure this project was going to happen I
got here and I was like I took like 10
classes and I was like learning Spanish
and I'm still learning Spanish but I was
doing it in such a desperate scared okay
whatever
next
uh this one was about her parents as you
mentioned to swash
yeah but once I got back to LA it became
serious like my parents were calling me
and saying hey people are asking us if
you've joined a cult I got an email from
Time Magazine asking for a statement on
my disappearance friends were reaching
out to me like hey what do I say people
are worried about you there was a moment
where I feel like I wasn't really my
highest self which is that something
about people concerned made it feel
safer to be gone for longer because I
had something to come back to you know
bro
what huh you waited to let people know
that you were okay longer because they
were already worried that's not fair to
your fans at all I don't understand the
logic of that statement I gotta listen
to it again what I can't but once I got
back to LA it became do you know how old
she is
she looks like 30.
or younger maybe I don't know 28 30 32
28 to 32
um famous birthdays has 27. oh that was
close yeah 28. I got an email from Time
Magazine asking for a statement on my
disappearance friends were reaching out
to me like hey what do I say people are
worried about you there was a moment
where I feel like I wasn't really in my
highest self which is that something
about people concerned made it feel
safer to be gone for longer I don't
understand that what does that mean
either
people were worried about me
so the urgency and worry
maybe maybe what she means is she liked
the attention yeah that people were
thinking about her
you know yeah which does kind of tie
back into when she claims that she
wanted to plant that seed and then be
gone for so long and then she stayed
gone for long because people were
interested I don't buy the Seed Theory
um
not buying a girl
not you girl her I know girl because I
had something to come back to you know
people were looking for a return and
there was safety in that and that was
helping the fear around coming back but
really what was going on why I didn't
just get on Instagram and say hey I'm
fine I'm not in a call is because I
think I needed to prove to myself that I
was going to put myself before other
people and before work and what I truly
needed like I couldn't as you say I
can't be bothered I couldn't be bothered
and then I have to get on it
where's the part about her parents she
said when she got back to Los Angeles
her parents called her and they were
like are you joining a cult everybody's
asking me if you're joining a cult right
yeah
so even she clearly wasn't talking to
her parents again that that disproves
her original theory that she did this on
purpose because clearly even the people
closest to her friends and family and
parents didn't know what the [__] was
going on either
by the sound of it
okay
so she pinned a comment after it
received some backlash that said
hi all I didn't really clarify this in
the video but I want to make it clear
that I never intended for people to
worry about me by the time I started
getting messages about it I was not in a
place to post anything online and the
longer I waited the harder speaking it
became I'm really sorry that I caused
people to worry it did and doing my best
Rick Justice says she's trolling 100 I
don't know anything about her so
I don't know it seems too detailed yeah
I agree it seems like she's she's and
she's pretty serious she wants to make a
documentary about it she like told she
was like production company if you're
interested like I would love to so it
sounds like it's a big project that
she's about to embark on I don't know
what's your evidence that she's trolling
yeah I agree has she done elaborate
stuff like this in the past I mean no
probably not right we do a little
trolling as well we do a little trolling
you're 100 in a cult I feel so strange
about this so many people were worried
for months this is very unsettling that
comment said top comments I'm studying
psychology I actually made an academic
work about Colts from the most deep spot
in my heart both of you get out of there
they can't they won't hear that though
no yeah also saying she came back and
felt disconnected from friends as a big
red flag one of the first things Colts
do is separate you from your friends and
family yeah I've been so fascinated by
Colts and the effects they have on
people but watching Alex for so long and
seeing her strangely devoted something
like this chills me to my core
you know what's really sad is thinking
about the parents like because she's she
can do it she can go to she she's
consenting basically to go join a cult
and there's nothing they can do you know
you see a lot of times the parents are
the ones spearheading these moments like
Nexium yeah there was uh a mom of one of
the girls who was in there interestingly
the the mom was instrumental in taking
down Keith and Nicole but her daughter
is still in the cold right she never she
never left yeah and she hates her mom
it's crazy what do you do as a parent
yeah I don't know
I'd probably go to war too I don't know
right it becomes your whole life mission
because what else can you but then you
but then you're kidding with the R Kelly
situation
right
but then it's like do you keep your door
open so that if they when they're ready
they come to you or do you go to war
with the cold
I personally would go to war but I think
it depends on the person you know it's
not easy probably
go against the cult it's a nightmare oh
yeah yeah that's that's Risky Business
yeah I need to say this as a long time
viewer I can assure you that if I ever
unsubscribe it's not because you don't
want to do revealing your secrets
anywhere your quote though probable
reason
I don't know what's worse Elks
purposefully letting us worry for months
on Ann about her possibly joining a
quote or the vaccines she did join a
cult and is gaslighting herself and
others into thinking it's not one
I'm glad she seems okay and happy though
Alex as someone who's been able to leave
a real cult
a real life quote I hear stories like
this one and it makes me so worried my
stomach actually hurts hearing you
describe similar things I suffered while
being abused isolation not being able to
get decent sleep being given happy drugs
starvation not engaging in anything but
the people in the place where all this
all occurred those things can be
dangerous I strongly encourage you to
take a break from the practice to
consider what is real and what is not
please eat and rest and take substances
in I'm assuming she said moderation
wow so interesting so my thought is yeah
she definitely joined that [__] oh
yeah the fact that there's a maestro
that's what really sends it home
that's what makes it a cult not like you
know a bunch of people just being
spiritual together and taking Iowa no
there's a maestro whose kids are there
[__] that bro
kids loved Hitler
kids love maestro
and his wife is the one sucking their
heads and puking all day this one was
just puking everywhere and they're like
she's holy she's so beautiful and pure
she's the best person who pukes
everywhere all the time and then I feel
different
well yeah well you know I feel bad for
her yeah me too what a weird thing
Talia said she had an enlightening
experience and is stepping out of the
norm calling it a cult and wearing
people is the issue here not her
experience
um
what was that I didn't understand this
person Talia is saying
she had a positive experience stepping
out of her Norm calling it a cult and
worrying people is the issue not her
experience it doesn't sound like a
positive experience though
she's disappeared left many people
wandering and worrying worried that's
what she's saying that's the problem not
the not what actually happened there
oh I don't know
super chats opinions no but I'm trying
to entertain it I mean the thing is we
don't know everything that happened but
I guaran [__] to you that there's not
good things happening there
guarantee it I would bet you that any
day well there's that Maestro so much
we've seen so much by now about Colts
and about what goes in there
it's never good stuff never never well
of course because occult by definition
has a psychotic egomaniac at the center
of it who was willing to go to any
lengths to manipulate and control people
for their own benefit and usually sexual
gratification all all
all um varieties of gratification that
you can get I mean it's it's that's what
a cult is
I wonder what call Tyler goes in
oh
are you part of maestro
Maestro's a symphony
hello my Symphony gather around
today you'll be playing the flute on my
deck
[Music]
call me Maestro everybody will be
practicing flute tonight
um play the violin show me your oboe
face yes now you'll be playing the
trombone on my dick got a huge stromb
owner
somebody replaced the trombone
Hunter said I was raised in a cult this
is extremely alarming yeah I mean this
this is not good for I don't care what
you say well all of our love literally
hope you're
excited for you are you saying love
yourself love bomb her you know that
that's it oh I take that back yeah
I don't I don't think there's I think
she's in too deep there's no saving her
I mean try I'm just telling you I don't
think you can pull her out at this point
well I'm serious I've only been a couple
months right people get deprogrammed
from colds yeah I'm telling you it takes
years you don't think the like insane
response of no it's just gonna drive her
further in we've seen so much no we've
seen so many documentaries about colds
it's true it's sad it's really sad that
I I totally believe it's going to be
what Ethan said she's gonna reach a
point of like she is nothing zero in the
bank no career no people left she'll
have physically nothing no belongings
and she'll have to figure out how to
escape this place and start over as an
adult 100 in society how do you start
over your life it's insane and it's it's
sick it's sad that quotes exist he's
gonna ruin her life utterly destroy her
spiritually mentally
and uh that's when she'll come back
sad but I've seen it so many times
she's just in too deep
I'm curious to follow it though if she
keeps making content yeah has she said
or done anything since uh posting this
video hasn't posted a video Let's see if
maybe Twitter tweets Instagram
they got her man you can tell by the way
she talking about it
she's in the I mean they got her to make
a whole recruitment video for two
million people
yeah you guys got me love you ever heard
of my friend Jenna
no clue who that is
the only things that she's posted are
about that video
like yeah
here's a George Bush actually receiving
the news on that fateful day
he right now
girl that is so tea is that you Kim you
made my vision yeah reality thank you it
was a super late submission but I
finished the videos okay oh my God here
I am I'm back he's back
um
I can't believe there are people in the
audience who either grew up in a cult or
had experience
yeah there's so many it's kind of
surprising yeah
um and the fact that you're listening to
this must mean that you've gone through
so much to get to this point because
also you can usually like not consume
any media even she said it yeah it's
always the same she said as silent as
possible yeah I wonder why because they
don't want you knowing what people
actually say about them the hunter said
it took me years and I even had one
parent who left the response will not
help people telling her it's a cult will
not help yeah well there's nothing
anyone can do at this point everything
is just going to drive her deeper and
deeper
and uh it's crazy it's a [__] crazy
thing yeah it's so incredible that
there's this phenomenon that keeps
repeating itself again and again because
I like imagining
the level of control
that it takes for like
a cult leader mm-hmm
to
get everybody sucked in and to
constantly be like
we're introducing these control measures
it's it's it's CR I don't know how they
even how is it not Orchestra that's like
illegal I don't understand that well
because it's like how do you define it
how do you define a quote you know I
mean to make a law about it like maybe
there needs to be some sort of
regulations I don't know yeah you know
about like you're not allowed to ask
people to starve or you're not allowed
to control when they go pee or if they
can call their family I don't know well
they deny that stuff
they would never they wouldn't admit to
that I guess and even then I mean it all
gets very fuzzy because you know at
least I can only speak to the laws in
this country but you know freedom of
religion is very much enshrined uh in
the Constitution and
where does a religion start in a cult
end it's kind of a very long yeah
Robin he says I go to war against the
cold for my child or close ones rather
than
them hate me then see I'd rather them
hate me than see them go down the worst
Road possible it's a tough call yeah
yeah
that's just the premise of it sounds
like it sounds like a beautiful
experience to go be in nature and
connect with yourself hold on this
comment says Alex is a big fan of you
guys you should have her on the Pod she
mentioned being inspired by your podcast
when she started hers
reach out I'd love to talk to you really
whoa maybe we can talk some sense bro I
I would love to talk to her that would
be so [__] interesting I'll totally
reach out and I'll be I'll be
understanding and sweet I'm not gonna be
combative no I just want to know about
maestro
have you have a good night
yo let's reach out what the f
uck something seems off I wonder if this
was her plan to join so she can make an
escape cult documentary no
there's nobody plant that's like
conspiracy theory thinking it's like
people don't plan like that everybody's
got their little plans it just happened
you know
but this is common too you saw it in
Nexium they want they want documentaries
because these people think that they're
participating in this uh revolutionary
thing that could save the world if only
people understood what they understand
and also as a cult leader the pr is good
and the recruitment is good so it's
common that they want to put out
uh documentaries and stuff like you know
uh Mark what's his name mark
Elliott Mark Elliott put out the you
know I've cured Tourette's via Nexium
have a good night my favorite author
Mark Twain that's a couch for show
yeah I think that was in uh Huck Finn a
celt yeah
I don't think they said for show back
then well you got a brush up one more
classic American League no they didn't
went out of style and then came back
I I don't know it sounds like um it
sounds far-fetched I mean she's going to
want to spread called PR yeah exactly I
would love
love to talk about yeah
well let's see we're coming near the end
of the show here thank you Olivia that
was very yeah
[Applause]
Reach Out 100
thank you so much you're very good at
watching it
I didn't know who that was to start but
now I'm very invested oh my God I love
that so I'm so invested well me too I
hope she's yo I'll do anything to get
her on the show
if she's a fan I want I would want I
want to do that for her yeah I'll take
Ayahuasca with her
you're going to say I'll go to the
retreat it's in Peru now do you think
that you will she's in Peru no not
tomorrow she's back in L.A but it's in
Peru was in Peru what what I missed that
detail yeah I missed that little early
no I'm not going to Pearl go to Peru no
are you gonna feel the same about having
her on once she blocks this episode as
soon as we get off the air because
there's probably like a 95 chance I will
yeah I will still talk to her okay yeah
if it gets blocked we'll just dispute
and right
620k pay Oscar Retreat let's go
oh [__]
drink that tea oh my God that's tea what
literally yeah this is [__] insane
so I just heard back our Monday episode
went yellow we watched that clip of the
guys
um in the shopping cart remember yeah
that's why
oh you gotta be kidding the whole
[__] podcast Jackass video the whole
podcast three and a half hours yellowed
because some dudes in a shopping cart it
wasn't gory or anything no we checked it
we checked it too he said when you had
to click show real because it's graphic
which we consider harmful dangerous acts
easily replicated by miners
who even [__] saw that like stupid
ouch
we got God that's so dumb man my own
hubris
I guess I'm not clicking any more of
those [__]
I didn't quite understand that I clicked
on what I guess on the Reel you had the
click a confirmation that says uh like
oh it was hidden and you have to click
to see it I see but what like on
Instagram that's Instagram what's it
have to do with YouTube dumb [__]
pissed me off dude so stupid you know
it's like you want me to be here and do
this business like I invest so much I'm
here I'm in I've got a business to run
it's just so stupid to me that they'll
they'll just take that from you for no
goddamn reason
we gotta go to rumble yeah Rumble baby
let's go dude that's it
I'm asking it doesn't matter what's in
the video just that I clicked the thing
I mean
he's probably gonna say Luke I know he
will
uh yeah yeah
well okay he was like I get
typical it sucks
this is the first time that's happened
to us in months I will say which is yeah
you know we've been we've been talks
we've been pretty lucky
I agree
but it's still [__] annoys me like
what other field aren't you gonna be in
where
they're like now
no income today
yeah sorry
let's just start uh stopping and
restarting the live stream every 10
minutes or so so we can uh so we can
isolate just uh every chunk of the
podcast the smart part one part two part
three I won't get really [__]
annoying well we do three and a half
hours that's what like 35 Parts you know
someone something like that that's cool
no problem
um it's like the old days I remember
YouTube the the video limit used to be
uh 10 minutes it did yeah so I can't
tell you how many uh pirated movies I
watched in uh 10 minutes is that right
yeah Twitter just announced they have
two hour video uploads now Elon Musk
just tweeted it out oh yeah and I well
I've seen people posting straight
bootlegs I watched the good chunk of
Avatar yeah
it's my favorite thing though it was up
for like days too there's just like
because you want such a [__] now he's
gonna have to deal with
yeah legal issues that he's never had
Twitter's never had to deal with posting
full movies awesome
oh uh somebody donated five dollars and
said just hit the button a bunch to undo
it just go back in time to Monday okay
we've done so much work though it would
be rewind time lose all that work in the
week so
well I think we hit everything you know
there was a World Health Organization
warned against artificial sweetener
we're gonna have to get Dr Ed's to call
in I hear a little giggle so yeah you'll
see me in love ready for that
I don't understand why you guys are
celebrating this horrible because they
eat because you recall love
he pushed back on Dr is listen
listen
I drink [__] like dude look I I am
dead if that's true like why are you
celebrating dude because I took a W yeah
everybody hold on
me and you used to argue about that okay
oh [__] guys okay
hold on hold on hold on talk to the
doctor IDs okay I mean look at what it
says continued construction Lids hell
hold on leave this first line continued
consumption doesn't reduce weight who
said it reduces weight
what read the second part of that
sentence no I could increase the risk of
typing and that was literally all me me
and love literally just said that we're
hesitant to believe it 100. everyone's
like why why are you hesitant they were
comparing it to kovitz you guys are
celebrating too early
with Dr Ed's I got annoyed with Dr Ritz
because he he wasn't clear enough that
it's not a it's a good alternative to
Coke but it's still very unhealthy no I
think it no that's a 10. first of all
unhealthy is in debate we're gonna have
to talk to him and get him but
definitely it is he was clear that it as
an alternative it's far superior than
drinking course okay of course but it's
still on itself that's in debate I mean
again read this some alternatives to
sugar when consumed long-term do not
serve to reduce body fat nobody claimed
that okay I don't even think Dr IDs
would say it's like water
he just drinks sweet and [__] hits that
diet he says I don't even drink water he
has like a water he said that's why I
was like that's okay I'm a little
hesitant I know he's an expert I'm not
saying he's wrong but I'm just 100 agree
that he was right well well well then I
still do because
um because by the way you guys not
drinking water is bad there's no way
Edge lives his life he says I don't ever
drink water there's no way
he also he also says that it's a good
way to V like wean off sugar like it
replaces the sugar intake you want but
it also does the opposite and you guys
are going to get schooled that if you if
you have a sugar uh craving
that is gonna trigger that too so you
eat more candy and stuff
the World Health Organization on Monday
warned against using artificial
sweeteners to control body weight
or reduce the risk of disease long-term
use is not effective and could pose
health risk again the thesis that
they're working on is odd like who I
personally don't drink diet drinks to
lose weight to control my it's like you
do it because you don't want to drink
500 grams of sugar
well but it's stupid like as a thesis
that's weird that's not interesting to
me these oh let me continue to read
these alternatives to sugar when
consumed long term do not serve to
reduce body fat nobody I mean nobody
thinks about that nobody thinks that by
a drinking diet you're going to lose
weight no but isn't I mean can't you
like the argument is that if you drink
five cans of coke a day you're gonna
gain weight that's not what they're
saying that's literally not what they're
saying it would say that drinking it is
associated with weight gain they're
saying it's not associated with reduced
body fat
right do people really be like yeah I'm
on a diet coke diet like I don't know
anything that's not a thing yeah but the
Assumption well some people do do that
well then that's right president Trump
that's not what we're advocating for uh
that's not what we're talking about the
recommendation applies to all people
except individuals with pre-existing
diabetes uh includes okay well whatever
the who recommends based on the review
of available evidence that agents did
that is part of a set of guidelines for
a healthy diets being rolled out by the
way does the World Health Organization
didn't they lose all credibility with
like kovid like they were telling people
not to worry about covid at all as
everybody was [__] dying like it's a
joke organization
well
different department
let's talk to Dr IDs doctor doctor IDs
doesn't drink water that's what he told
me ask him yourself next week when he
calls in and then Wednesday PMP I want
to talk uh damages
okay yeah we can do that we can line
that up affirmation
I'm not here on Wednesdays but not
drinking water
no it's a little a little much right
that's us well listen listen to this
conclusion which everybody knows on face
is absurd this guy misses or Miss Mick
Burnett who's a licensed dietitian
nutrition was quoted saying it's not
surprising oh wait I misread that it's
not surprising to me that the World
Health Organization doesn't
differentiate in health benefits between
regular soda and diet soda that's absurd
like everybody knows that's [__]
stupid they're both processed foods dude
there's like 50 grams of sugar in coke
you're telling me that's not worse
that is what they're telling that's
saying that no no difference I think
doctor is
you could you could interpret it the
other way is that sugar right doesn't
increase risk of diabetes at all have at
it drink as much coke as you want that's
how I'm going to interpret it no but no
but I don't need sugar has calories nope
doesn't matter they said there's no
calories in Diet Coke no difference in
the in the weight gain you're right
that's what they said is it really
diabetes so I'm going all out
they are for consumers and so uh
I haven't drank water for a year since
that episode so I was drinking and
you're fine look at you though you're
alive water before my boxing fight
you're alive [__] for my boxing
fight right he could have won yeah he
could have won the damn water on your
hair yes the water would have protected
your [__] liver everyone in the gym
was like yo drink water I was like no
[__] that I talked to the professional
like that gamer sup only
um
I'm trying to catch the people need to
consider other ways to reduce sugar-free
intake such as consuming food with
naturally occurring sugar like fruit
okay yeah everyone else fruits good to
eat dummies
or unsweetened food and beverages L next
who's eating that [__] you said that
non-sugar sweeteners are not essentially
dietary factors and have no nutritional
value nobody said they have nutritional
value people should reduce the sweetness
of the diet altogether starting in life
early in life to improve their health
this is I have a feeling this is a
nothing Burger yeah this is pretty
stupid I feel like the New York Times
click baited us
I feel like they're not saying anything
and they just wanted a fat juicy title
we invited Dr IDs I'm just saying it up
for himself he's coming next week he's
and I'm just warning you guys Howard no
he's on vacation he is on vacay right
now living it up and he'll be back very
soon
exiled in shame no AKA laying on the
beach and getting some rays took a
vacation I I think this is a little bit
biased because we found him because he
had your opinion we should find someone
of the other opinion because I
can find someone
he always has good opinions Dr Ding yeah
but he's not like a medical researcher I
know but he's got good it was actually
his specialty he's a good researcher
okay but I don't know how he feels about
it sure ask Doctor Martin
I mean we tried to set up a debate with
the carnivore and the doctor drinks
water
I bet you he does king king we don't
know that
um it's a roll of the dice you guys
should not be celebrating I'm telling
you until Dr IDs comes here because
y'all are gonna look even dumber than
you did before I'm going back to the
episode already I'm screen recording
chat
go ahead do whatever you need to I mean
I'm not even this is people celebrating
for me Burger nothing Burger dude they
click baited people with this title it
doesn't say [__] they go they go yeah um
so artificial sweeteners doesn't have
nutrition duh
no [__]
I I I'm not I mean I am with you I drink
uh Coke Zero but I just think it's not
it cannot be zero there's like bad
health benefits and like sparkling water
and [__] like that it's sparkling
there's never has bad health benefits I
mean I mean technically but to say it's
like water it's crazy sparkling water is
like water
I was just making a extreme example okay
but it is like water no I think he's
saying that saying that drink in it is
just like drinking water I'm not making
it well first of all Diet Coke has
caffeine so it's not okay just straight
off the bat that's one good point yeah
caffeine
um or any diet let's just talk about a
diet juice whatever with diet if you're
drinking let's say like a artificially
sweetened soda yeah fruit flavor with no
caffeine yes
they're in no sodium no nothing it's
just like carbonated water and uh and
artificial aspartime or whatever
according to what Dr Ed's claims as a
high level high level medical researcher
and and hero of the people
and Tick Tock infallible hero of the
people and Tick-Tock it's not only about
his credential here he um
he he makes that claim yeah that it's as
good as water he does yeah he was pretty
adamant about it but let's see let's see
what he says so this I mean you create
some great favor there we go way back on
this what did I say in your favor
like the like the uh what's it called uh
uh maybe help me out here what's what
did you just say you say by saying that
it's worse because it has caffeine for
one I think love is just changed no that
doesn't support you at all drinking a
drink with caffeine it it's every you
know caffeine dehydrates you well I'm
not talking about Diet Coke hydrating
you that's different yeah but that was
never my my point uh my original point
when I argued with Dr Ritz was that uh
Coke Zero is not like water it you know
the doctor is no no no no no no you I
don't think you I don't think that's
what happened Dr is does not believe
Coke Zero is like water I guarantee you
that there's caffeine in it it makes it
different because caffeine is uh I don't
what's it deriatic or what is it called
diuretic is that what it is Diet oh yeah
diuretic
which means it dehydrates you so I think
the best analogy is like a sparkling
water with with artificial sweetener no
sodium yeah
that's what Dr IDs drinks he doesn't
drink a caffeinated one
no that doesn't work either
I thought he said Diet Coke
what'd I say I just remember him saying
that he slams Diet Coke all the time no
he had like a no he had a bottle of
water with some yellow [__] you're right
it was just the original argument was
about Diet Coke but you're right he he
had the
I guarantee that he will agree that Diet
Coke is not water right no
no I would hope so yeah well he's he's
uh on vacation formulating his response
right now okay good and we'll see yeah
but I'm telling you guys this is blow
this is a silly [__] dude you guys gonna
look so silly when he comes on he's
gonna come on strutting you know what I
mean big dick doctor is
um
that's what I'm talking about man come
on man
all right let's
all right let's follow the day guys
um well we got that to look forward to
next week all right we also have uh
Martin coming in so it's the hydration
liquid Oh Martin um
visiting us tomorrow or next week
we'll be reviewing water talk if I'm not
here please ask him for me how does it
feel about what
what about doctor is not drinking water
yes he's not a city triggered
have you seen the Porsche Martin Drive
nobody I think you know the man is
basically dude yeah exactly
the man beautiful Porsche yeah and he
loves Mills he told us that last time
that's right he loves water that's true
MILFs MILFs yeah I I asked him what
context did he say that I don't remember
the context but he Fest if you like
Mills and he did so that was a good
intuition especially so yeah he said who
doesn't all right yeah yeah which fair
enough interesting all right guys have a
great great weekend wait we should
mention too uh there's BTS of Sam making
all of the fika fish dishes
in the evening is it ready yeah it's
ready and I have a thumbnail I just no
it's ready I got it okay so in just a
little bit that we'll be going up yeah
also if you're looking for Content Ila's
Vlog is up as well as the the missing
episode of the podcast which we erased
uh sorry we had to erase the original
pray for us that's in a different tab
than life because again YouTube is
trying to [__] ruin my life so alive
is where they usually you gotta get if
you're on a computer you click videos
tabs or mobile too very confusing on the
home page you don't even see it because
it's just past lives videos it's so
stupid but it's there
um thank you members and thank you to
all of the generous don't um donators
and people who are buying memberships
for everyone that's super nice super
amazing 500. wow
500.
500 Subs man man
I like his voice he could be a good like
uh
it could be a good metal finger I just
said that yesterday I think so yeah well
and few off the rail intros I've made
yeah some metal [__] oh yeah
Kim Kardashian yeah
all right guys have a great weekend we
love you all see you next week uh for
another
action-packed week we're here every day
every weekday let's [__] do it it's
the H3 podcast ain't nobody out there to
do what we do in it the best show I'm
drinking drink your diet coke this
weekend it's water yeah I drink
all right see you guys go
Kim Kardashian
[Music]